Experience,
everybody.
My guest today,
if you've ever seen the movie Gasland or gas land to the man who made it,
created it and uh,
the,
the best friend of the oil industry,
Josh Fox,
ladies and gentlemen,
what's up dude,
thanks for doing this.
I really appreciate it.
I'm happy to be here.
You know,
I uh,
I put on Twitter and I put on a,
you know,
online on my message
board people were talking about this Josh Fox from gas land movie and you either
have people who love you who are so happy for what you're doing or there's
people and even people that don't even have a vested interest in the oil
business that get really aggressive about like debunking your claims or calling
you a liar or calling you fraudulent.
I think those people are mostly not people.
I think they're from the oil industry really.
I mean if you really look into it,
a lot of those Twitter accounts,
they have like 10 followers or five followers or zero followers and then they
are,
or you have like hyper conservative Twitter people who,
who like echo those.
It's,
it's,
it's a pro oil lobby,
echo chamber.
Well,
the hyper conservative peep that is,
that's a thing that people do do.
That's like the same people that deny climate change,
the same people to deny,
you know,
the direct link there.
You see the climate change deniers now having in,
in this whole new fracking denial,
uh,
camp,
right?
And that's been a sustained campaign for the last six years.
But it's not so surprising considering that when we first heard from the oil
industry,
everything they said was untrue.
So when they first came to my backyard,
right in Pennsylvania to lease our land,
to lease the land of all my neighbors to come to the Delaware River basin,
their whole claim was that this was completely environmentally friendly.
And you know,
we probably won't even drill here and you should just take this free money.
And they didn't let anyone know what the real consequences of this stuff was.
Did they know what the real consequences where you think so?
Oh yeah.
Well,
there's a number of ways to prove that.
They know.
I mean they,
they disclose to their shareholders when they're courting for you dollars in the
financial world that there is the possibility of spills and have these kinds of
things have water contamination.
So they,
they make their investors aware of the fact that they could be sued down the
line or something like that.
So that's one way that we know that they know,
but they know,
I mean,
they know what they're doing.
They have,
um,
uh,
reports that we show in gas.
Then part two,
partially because of their denialism that show their own investigations into
their leaks,
into their contamination.
Because when they leak oil and gas into an aquifer,
they're not
recovering that oil or gas.
So that means it's a profit loss for them.
Right?
They're not investigating this because at some they want to not contaminate
water supplies.
They investigated it because,
um,
it's,
it's loss of product.
So when that oil or gas leaks out the side of their gas wells for oil wells,
which they've punctured through the aquifers,
they're at a loss.
And currently one of their studies,
you know,
oil industry,
his own studies shows that about 40% of the oil and gas wells in the Gulf of
Mexico are leaking,
um,
that they have very,
very high leakage rates,
um,
in horizontal wells,
like 60 to 70% in studies that they did in Alberta.
And these are studies that were done by Conoco Phillips 60 to 70%.
Yup.
Jesus clubs,
the wells,
not saying that they're,
the wells are leaking 67%,
but that 60 to 70% of them are leaking.
Oh Wow.
Currently so,
so,
um,
society,
petroleum engineers,
uh,
did a report on this 2012,
I think,
and their PowerPoint slides were leaked to me in which they said 35% of all oil
and gas wells in the world.
And there are 1.8 million of them are currently leaking.
So they know,
well,
they know what's going on.
Um,
so,
you know,
to go out there and do this kind of vicious
attack campaign against the films is just that it's the same thing that the
tobacco industry did.
And the same thing that they're all industry did with climate change.
Little different than the tobacco industry of course,
because the idea is that there is some benefit to this fracking that sort of
cancels out the environmental concerns.
There were benefits to smoking.
That's what they say.
Yeah.
But I mean,
financial benefits of smoking,
smoking makes you feel good.
Yeah.
But I mean,
finance cost benefits to communities that,
uh,
you know,
employ these people.
I mean,
that's a lot of the pressure.
I know in Canada,
like I've talked to people about the oil industry in Canada and they're very,
there's two sides.
There's the people who greatly benefit from the oil industry.
There's so many people that have jobs up there.
And then there's so many people that have seen those,
um,
overhead photos.
You've seen those a when they fall out past Edmonton,
when they fly over these areas where they just decimated large chunks of,
that's incredible.
And you see that I just flew from Houston to La Cause I was coming back from
this trip where we were shooting in the Amazon,
in the,
in the jungle investigating oil spills,
investigating deforestation for this new film on Climate Change.
But when you fly from Houston to La for the first hour leaving Texas,
you go through the Eagle Ford Shale,
you go through a lot of oil exploration areas.
Those places are decimated.
I mean it is unbelievable.
You look at out the window of the plane and you see Justin gas well pad after
scorched landscape after,
I mean it's just wild apocalyptic.
It's really um,
I myself have never taken that route.
I've seen a lot of the new fracking fields as you go.
Like if you would go for from Salt Lake City to fort worth or something,
you'll see your capacity.
A lot of them in Colorado,
but I was,
my jaw was on the floors looking at these yesterday.
It's,
it's very weird how many people are willing to sacrifice like big chunks of,
of natural landscape and environments in order to profit.
There's like,
there's like this point of like d there's a point of diminishing returns.
Like if you could ruin like the up like a,
say a small patch of land where a house is,
if that,
if you knew that's all it's going to be ruined.
This is one spot and not have that spot.
We're going to get enough oil to power Los Angeles period.
You know everybody be cool.
Yeah.
That's the only one lot.
Fuck it.
Well look,
I mean so much of this is a discovery and a learning process,
right?
I mean we learned that smoking was bad for us.
We learned that climate change was happening.
We were learning that fracking is devastating to water supplies in air and then
it has a huge effect on the climate,
not only because of the gas burned and the CO2 burned from the gas,
but also because of the methane leakage,
which is a huge other piece of this all.
Because when you're drilling all these holes in the ground and you're running
pipelines for natural gas,
you're going to be leaking a lot.
Right?
And what they're discovering is that methane is,
you know,
um,
about 80 to a hundred times more potent than co two is in the atmosphere.
Carbon dioxide as a warming agent.
So it's like if see o two is one blanket methane is a hundred blankets,
so you're that much hotter by,
by leaking methane,
which means if you're at anywhere,
you know more than one to 3% of that methane is leaking into the atmosphere as
Ron Methane,
then you're worse than or on a par with like coal,
which is the worst of the fossil fuels.
Currently in Los Angeles,
they do both production and transportation and consumption of natural gas and
methane in that whole cycle in Los Angeles,
the measurement was 17% of it was leaking into the atmosphere.
So this drilling for natural gas,
um,
you know,
is on a par or way worse than coal in terms of effects for climate.
But what I'm saying is that that,
you know,
we have to,
the overall message here is not okay,
we're going to ban fracking here.
We had to keep it out of this place.
We care to keep these things a localized effects.
The overall message is starting to become very clearly.
We are,
we have to start living much more sustainably,
which doesn't necessarily mean a whole sale change in the way that we do things.
Um,
we can still have,
you know,
podcasts,
computers,
we just have to start to switch our energy source.
I mean,
if you can imagine the technology that's sitting in front of you right now,
you know,
what would be the equivalent of that a hundred years ago?
An abacus and a bull horn or something?
Well,
actually if you never changed the,
your technology,
well that's the same stuff.
That's the,
these are the same fuels that we were using a hundred years ago.
Oh,
we have new fuel sources.
We have solar,
we have wind power.
Um,
they have tons of energy innovations,
but we have left are we have,
because of the power of the oil and gas industry and the coal industry,
we have let sector of
our technological development be completely inhibited and,
and,
and doesn't Prague progress.
But now you're starting to see it just the have,
they have so much money to too much money,
so much power.
Now when you see these responses to your documentary,
I mean,
even the New York Times had some sort of a negative response to two documentary.
What did New York Times was really mixed?
Um,
in fact,
a year after the documentary came out,
it was the day after the Oscars that we didn't,
when we were nominated for best documentary for gasoline,
part one,
the day after a front page article ran about,
um,
uh,
gas drilling contamination hitting rivers and contaminating water supplies.
And that was the first in a series of about 10 articles by Ian or being an inner
being and one of the best investigative reporters for the Times.
And he was actually,
he told me later a year later did,
he was asked to investigate all these claims of fracking contamination because
they wanted to find out if my film was true.
And you know,
because obviously there was this gigantic smear campaign is still is against the
films.
And um,
he came back with,
with even more evidence than we had turned up that fracking was contaminated
water supplies that it was doing,
do an addendum who,
what in the New York Times like Combo.
You can look up the drilling down series right now.
Right.
But what,
what they wrote about your,
your documentary was he was fairly critical when I remember,
I don't read reviews.
If it was the film review,
Oh,
I'm,
I'm interested in what their political reporting as though,
well,
I mean,
I just think that was the New York Times.
there's one of these headlines Gasland debunked even in New York Times.
This was on one of the websites that I write,
but that's probably not the truth.
That's probably a headline written by the oil and gas industry pointing to align
in the New York Times.
It may be as critical about from one point or another,
but this is the thing that they do.
They will take a sentence out of context because sentences that I've said and
put them out of context and then say,
I said this,
you know what I mean?
Or said.
The New York Times said this.
There's very little checking up on all of that stuff.
But the bottom line,
Joe is,
um,
New York state of New York just did exhaustive seven year process of
environmental review and a two year health study.
I'm not an activist,
he kind of government,
they were extraordinarily cautious about doing this over a period of seven years
and they just came back with a complete and total ban on fracking.
Yeah.
Indicates everything that we've been doing and all the reporting that we've been
doing because they just said,
look,
this isn't about activism.
We,
we,
we got,
yeah,
obviously the protestors got our attention,
but this was about a scientific review.
And when you look at a scientific review,
the health commissioner in New York state said,
I wouldn't want my kids living there this period.
End of story.
What have been the criticisms though?
And what,
I mean,
if you,
if you broke down what you've heard,
that people
try to debunk about your film.
Like what,
what the oil industry or whoever was behind it,
the far right wing
ultra conservative groups that decided to attack,
what would their criticism,
well,
their mom,
their mantra in spite of this preponderance of evidence is,
you know,
hydraulic fracturing has never contaminated water supplies that sound over and
over and over.
That seems to be impossible.
It's crazy.
Yeah.
But it's like saying smoking doesn't cause lung cancer.
It's like saying smoking is not good for it.
Smoking is good for you.
You know,
it's crazy.
Right?
But see the point of this,
and I put out a short film,
um,
a couple of years back and it was,
it was in rolling stone and it was,
it's online,
you can watch it for free.
It's called the sky is pink and that's at pink sky.
And why.com so pink sky and wine.com and sky is pink.
The point is not to make a plausible argument in this case,
right?
Smoking is good for you.
Climate change doesn't exist.
There's no such thing as fracking water contamination.
The point is simply to create the appearance that there's a debate.
Okay?
So if you go on,
if you and I go on the news,
right,
and you're from New Orleans street and I'm a scientist and I go out and I say
the sky is blue and the oil industry says no,
this guy is actually pink.
Nine Times out of 10,
the anchor sitting there is going to go,
well,
the facts are being debated.
So it gives,
instead of going outside and looking,
this is specialized information.
So you don't necessarily know who's telling the truth,
right?
You have to do a lot of research to figure out or watch these films to figure
out who's telling you the chance to experience that.
There's a debate,
gives the public,
the public gets confused and says,
oh,
well maybe the science isn't really in now.
Maybe we don't know enough.
So that staves off regulation and this was the tobacco industries,
um,
strategy for decades.
And it worked.
They funded bogus science at university saying smoking was good for you and all
these kinds of things.
And this is what's worked with climate as well.
The Cha,
you know,
99% of scientists or something like this,
97% of scientists say that climate change is,
um,
uh,
a manmade occurrence.
And then there's 3% of scientists that say from the,
that work for the oil industry that say dough,
it's all fake.
And that that does exacerbated by human beings.
They're not saying that it's caused by human beings are saying that it's a
natural sort of state of constantly,
there's a cycle of,
of climate change.
And we,
yeah,
we should be,
we can't predict.
Right.
But it seems to be accelerating because of human beings.
Oh yeah.
I mean,
but that's the scientific consensus.
And what just came out on fracking.
Um,
there are 400 plus scientific peer reviewed studies that have come out and we're
hitting a point of an explosion of the scientific research on fracking.
One paper a day is coming out right now.
Now,
remember in 2008 when I started this,
there were no scientific peer reviewed studies really on the effects of
hydraulic fracturing at this level.
Now you're seeing one come out a day and 98% of them are saying there are health
effects,
uh,
problems.
95% of them are saying air problems.
Um,
76% of them are saying like water contamination,
or,
or I may be off by one or two percentages here,
but this is the basics.
Um,
and if you,
uh,
look at a very dry,
boring website called physicians,
scientists and engineers for healthy energy,
all those,
um,
peer reviewed scientific papers on fracking and their effects.
And there are many different categories,
right?
Earthquakes,
health effects,
air,
water contamination,
um,
social costs.
Uh,
these,
you can see a cross referencing of those peer reviewed scientific studies.
So when you actually do your work and you get away from what is this atmosphere
within a media where anybody could say anything and it is a goes untested,
right?
Anything that isn't refuted is all of a sudden true.
So when you read an in,
in on a website,
oh,
gas and debunked by this source or whatever and you don't go and find out,
and they do,
they go to great lengths to kind of hide where this information or that headline
or this thing is coming from.
Um,
you know,
it,
it casts an aura of doubt.
And that idea that the facts are in doubt,
that there's a debate going on is very,
very useful to them,
to stave off regulation,
to intimidate politicians,
to quell the public's fears,
all sorts of things that are,
um,
would be useful in terms of movement.
Now,
why would,
we'll have so many fans.
It's because you got millions of people right now in America right now,
15 million people live within one mile of a gas wall.
And the proposal is to,
you know,
double,
triple,
quadruple that you know,
or even more,
um,
those people know that these films are telling the truth because their lives
depend on doing that research,
right?
If you live in an area that's about to be fracked and you don't know what to do,
you're going to do your homework because all of a sudden your entire property
values are going to go down.
Your kids are going to be living in an area that's potentially unsafe.
Your water could go south.
So you're going to go and do that research and gas sign is going to be really
good starting point for you on our website costs in the movie.com is going to be
a good starting point for you.
So when you've dug into it and you know that the safety of your neighborhood and
the conditions in which you currently live depend on you having knowledge and
using that knowledge to campaign,
um,
in a government,
in a situation where the oil and gas industry has a budget times more resources
than you do,
right?
Then you're going to hold up these phones is something which are groundbreaking
and that,
that are helpful to you.
And that was the whole point of them in the first place,
right?
The point of these films,
you know,
like a guy like me who's never made a documentary before with a budget of like
$5,000 in a beat up 90 to Camry traveling around the country,
you're talking about an issue that nobody ever talked about.
This was not,
this was not,
uh,
um,
the ambition that I,
with not to,
uh,
Jen and HBO and make it to the Oscars or do all this stuff.
It was just to basically educate my community because I was scared.
Who ever thought that this film would become popular.
It's ridiculous even to imagine it.
What did you think when you were making this?
And nobody had had covered this subject before and you were making this and as
it's going along,
you know your lighting people's water on fire and,
and I've even seen that attempted to be debunked,
which I found really fascinating when people were saying,
well you know you could like people's water on fire before all of this.
Like okay,
maybe,
maybe one or two fucked up places where some sort of gas had leaked into the
water.
But I mean you're talking about people that didn't use to be able to do it then
there was fracking.
Now they can like their water on fire.
Yes.
I mean that's a weird thing.
Lighting your water on fire is a fucking weird thing for anybody to like poo poo
that and make it look like it's no big deal.
It goes along with that whole climate denial sort of right wing attitude,
this weird team thing.
It's idealistic or I idealogue idea.
We know what these ideologies that people subscribe to,
whether it's pro progressive or conservative,
they get locked into these things and they just say what the talking points are
and that's one of them.
You know,
the,
the real reason is because to admit that climate change is a problem and admit
the oil and gas is a problem,
would upend their entire political and economic philosophy.
So they have kind of cornered themselves into it denial.
But it's because the truth of it is that when we have these types of,
uh,
energy structures and political structures and economic structures,
you know what the answer is,
is public sector development,
the answer is collective responsibility.
The answer is how do we take on these ideas of sustainability as a,
as a society.
Now,
all of those things are,
are anathema to rampant,
deregulated,
international,
global,
Mega Corporation capitalism,
right?
That system wants you to go to Walmart to drive there.
You know,
to use a lot of resources to never really invest in the public space to make
sure that corporations have deregulated,
um,
the workforce so that we pay people less and less.
All of these things that so called conservatives are married to.
Um,
the underpinning of a lot of those values is
you have to deny climate change.
You have to deny that there's things that are being people who are being harmed
by this system.
And that's not unusual.
Like,
you know,
we live in a place,
we live in a society of increasing social and economic inequality.
A lot of that inequality is underpinned by a basic economic philosophy that's
created an oil and gas is a huge part of that.
So you can't listen to the science at a certain point because your entire other
world will fall apart at that moment.
So it's kind of,
it's kind of sad,
you know?
Um,
because now you've got people with cell phones in their pockets,
right?
Whose entire lives depend on science working,
denying science every single day.
And that's crazy because you want science to work so that your tires don't
explode on your car when you're driving down the highway at 65 miles an hour.
You want science to work,
um,
the aerodynamics of your vehicle.
You want to make sure your plane doesn't crash.
You want your cell phone to work.
You want your modern medicine to keep you in your relatives healthy and alive.
And yet when it comes to the other effects of fracking,
contamination,
climate change,
all of these things,
all of a sudden science can't,
doesn't matter.
Well,
I don't think it's a coincidence that the right wing is also connected
inexorably with religious fundamentalism.
I mean,
and the religious fundamentalism is also a denial of science and a lot of ways,
you're,
you're looking at sort of the same sort of car compartmentalize thinking that
allows people to think that the earth was made in 10,000 years ago in six days.
Well,
I think that there's,
I think that there's definitely a correlation between some of the things in the
past,
you know,
um,
uh,
Galileo,
Copernicus,
these were challenged,
challenged is putting it mildly in prison.
But if you look at what the pope is saying right now,
he's a different Dude,
Huh?
Unbelievable.
He's roaming.
He's so,
these don't think,
these don't have to be in conflict,
right?
The pope is saying,
well,
yeah,
we've,
science is the way that God created things and he's just showing us how that
works.
Now,
whether you believe that or not,
there's always a,
uh,
a way to absorb these things.
And,
and I,
I think that,
you know,
or when you look at something like Fritjof capra is work the Tao of physics,
when you're looking at,
you know,
extreme eastern philosophies and how they connect with what physicists are doing
at the deepest level.
So you don't have,
it doesn't have to be that way.
I just think that,
um,
I don't know what motivates people to deny science.
I couldn't crawl inside that mental space.
Um,
but I do know what causes people,
um,
to,
uh,
to need science and to need information.
And that's a very profound impulse I think in people.
And I think that that you need to have cross referencing.
You need to have multiple sources.
You need to,
I mean,
every single one of these scenes in these films,
Hbo,
you know,
and their lawyers checked out and we had to submit thousands and thousands of
pages of references to other work and to the science to clear all of these
scenes.
We were actually nominated for an Emmy for research,
for gas and air port to has anything been challenged legally?
I mean,
the things that you guys have said,
nope.
Nothing.
No.
Well,
that's kind of zero.
That says a lot,
doesn't it?
I mean this,
this,
and this day age where people will sue over almost anything.
It would seem like they would just start dragging you in a court just to fuck
with you.
Well,
um,
they've done that to some filmmakers.
I'm very,
I feel very fortunate that that hasn't happened.
How come it hasn't happened to you?
Well,
you work in for that.
My legal team,
my,
my legal advice that we got through the,
you know,
the,
uh,
I'm not sure if I'm supposed to repeat this kind of thing,
but they said,
you know,
if they did that,
it would be like Gaslamp three on steroids because we would have to discovery
into their work.
Oh,
I see.
So if I wanted to go into you,
you would be able to go dig deep and find out how much they actually know.
Yeah.
Um,
and I think that it was interesting because the first film,
they did crazy stuff.
They,
they attack the Oscars for giving us a nomination.
This practically handed us the Oscar.
We had no chance in hell of winning the Oscar,
you know,
I mean it was clear that one of the other films was going to win.
Like we were the underdog,
you know,
and then they started to attack the Oscars and all of a sudden we were like,
oh my God,
my publicist was screaming up and down going,
you can't pay for it,
but like this,
it's like,
you know,
all the attacks on the film.
And the first film caused,
I think an enormous amount of interest in the movie.
Um,
and the second film they backed off.
They didn't attack it hardly at all.
We got one day where Grover Norquist and Glenn back and a bunch of people sort
of lined up and said some stuff.
But it was,
yeah,
it was Kinda nice to get still enough to,
that's nice.
Did he cry?
Um,
I don't,
I just cried.
I mean,
it's best way.
I think if somebody said,
you know,
you're judged,
your life should be judged by the measure of your enemies.
So if Glenn Beck and these other crazy people are are,
are against me,
I kind of feel like that's all right.
Yeah,
that's a good sign.
Or if,
well,
he's just one of those guys where it's like,
he's in such a weird spot now that kinda anything he says,
you know,
automatic Oh,
fucking Glenn Beck said that like,
ah,
you know,
it's like a Nancy grace type thing.
Like,
Oh Nancy grace is talking shit about.
Yeah,
it's sad.
It's really sad that we have,
uh,
provided airspace.
But,
you know,
look,
honestly,
I don't think the films were popular because,
um,
you know,
all of a sudden this was like,
uh,
well,
I mean,
I think that some of the visual scenes,
you know,
of letting water on fire in both films,
did a lot.
But I do think that the real reason that films were popular is because so many
places are under siege from the oil and gas industry.
This is a moment where the oil and gas industry is trying to expand in a way
that they domestically onshore in a way that they haven't ever.
So that same uh,
Society of Petroleum Engineers,
PowerPoint that I talked about,
it said also that the oil and gas industry plans to drill more oil and gas wells
in the next 10 years than they've drilled in the last hundred years.
Okay?
So that means they want to drill 2 million more oil and gas wells in the United
States.
That's a state of insanity that's drilling the United States into Swiss cheese.
Do you know that Exxon Mobile,
Exxon Mobil one company spends $100 million a day looking for new oil and gas?
That's 100 million a day,
a day.
Now we want a renewable energy economy.
We wanted solar and wind.
You know,
you could do it.
In fact,
in the new climate agreement between the United States and China,
China committed to building 800 to a thousand gigawatts of renewable energy
power in China by 2030.
So that's 15 years from now,
right?
800 to a thousand gigawatts is the amount of energy that the United States uses
for his power grid.
So if we want it to do all of our power and renewable energy in 15 years,
we would,
we could do it.
We would simply have to do what the Chinese are doing.
We're,
we're,
we're not in a state where we can't get out of this problem.
We can get out of this problem.
The bigger problem is how much control the oil and gas industry exerts upon our
government and our media.
That is the resources you're talking about are so staggering.
$100 million a day just looking forward to new oil and gas.
And that's just one company,
a lot of companies,
right?
And the fact of the matter is,
um,
some very smart scientists,
and this was pointed out by bill McKibben,
um,
did calculations for how much more oil and gas we could burn.
Um,
because you know,
there's a,
there's a sort of budget in the atmosphere for how much carbon dioxide we can
put into the atmosphere and methane and what they came up with is 565 gigatons.
We can burn approximately 565 more gigatons worth of carbon dioxide into the
atmosphere if we're going to stay below two degrees of warming.
Now we're near one degree of warming now and that's already wreaking havoc on
climate system.
Superstorms droughts,
floods,
you know,
if to two degrees though is the limit,
um,
that a lot of governments have agreed to try to keep global warming under two
degrees if we want to keep it under two degrees and two degrees is bad.
Like at two degrees,
you lose 30% of the species on the planet.
Two degrees is bad.
But if we want to keep it below two degrees,
our carbon budget is 565 gigatons.
Now currently proven reserves that the oil and gas and coal industry has said,
we have these reserves in the ground because I want,
and gas and coal industries have two bank accounts.
They have money in the bank and they have oil and gas and coal in the ground.
Now,
if you take all the oil and gas and coal that's in the ground,
not including fracking and all these unconventional resources,
but what they say that we have that that amounts to 2,765 gigatons or sudden
change,
so almost 2,800 almost five times the amount that we're allowed to burn.
So even so,
they're looking for more,
right?
They're spending $100,000 a day looking for more.
But we already know that if they burned everything that they say they have,
we'd be talking about six,
seven,
eight degrees warming.
This is like telling the oil and gas world that they have to write down 80% of
their assets.
They're just gone because either their business model fails or the planet fails.
So is it just denying this because it's convenient because there's still
extracting money and because they know that if they keep going right now,
they're fine and a certain point,
maybe they'll deal with it in the future.
I mean,
what is,
what's the thought process behind it?
They address it at all.
It's called Rex Tillerson,
the CEO of Exxonmobil,
and ask him,
he doesn't take calls.
He doesn't take calls.
He's too busy,
but you know what he,
you know,
recently he just did.
He actually sued his town because they were going to put a fracking water tower
and the view of his a ranch mansion in Texas for 5 million.
I heard about that.
That's hilarious.
Yeah.
He's,
he's making,
I think it's something like $100,000 an hour,
but the man can't.
The man can't.
The man can't grasp the irony of him trying to keep fracking out of his own
backyard.
We probably just thought it would never come up.
There's con,
but you see what I'm trying to get at here.
The connectivity of this moment and future planning is not adding up.
He's not,
he's not going,
oh,
maybe the press would find out about this and rose to me for like a week.
He's not fighting.
He's not saying that to himself.
What?
He's in the same way.
He's not saying,
Oh,
maybe we should stop producing this stuff because we're going to rose the planet
for centuries.
You know,
like,
this is the problem.
Um,
or it's,
is part of the problem,
the main argument against it is that we need this oil that we don't have enough,
uh,
alternative energy sources right now to live the life that we're living to power
our cities.
Is that not true?
Not True.
We actually oil right now because,
because,
well,
you have to phase it out.
Okay.
But definitely in terms of the unconventional sources,
right?
Fracked gas,
fracked oil,
tar sands development,
mountain top removal for coal,
all of these new expansions.
DEF definitely,
definitely not necessary.
But I asked the same question several years ago because I didn't want to be a
hypocrite.
I didn't want to say,
oh,
well,
we can't do this.
So just because it's in my backyard,
you know.
So,
um,
myself and the wonderful actor,
Mark Rufallo and some renewable energy bankers who live in California.
Um,
we asked a guy named Mark Jacobson who worked at Stanford University if he would
please look into a heat.
Stanford Mark Jacobson at Stanford had done a report that said,
um,
we could get off of all,
uh,
all fossil fuels for all purposes by 2030 and he mapped out how to do it.
The problem with solar and the problem with wind is that they're intermittent,
right?
So the wind doesn't blow and sun doesn't
always shine.
And if,
unless you want to have massive storage batteries or something,
you kind of need to deal with that problem.
But what he's discovered was that there was a curve for when solar worked and
occur for when wind work and that they inverted so that if you bundled wind and
solar together,
you would solve the intermittency problem up to something like 95%.
So when the sun is not shining,
the wind is often blowing,
right?
When there's clouds,
you're going to have a windier day.
The wind blows harder at night.
So you have this ability to bundle wind and solar in a way that gets you past
this problem.
And he mapped this out for the whole world.
So we asked him,
could he please map it just for one state,
for New York state.
Um,
and he said,
absolutely,
let's do that.
He devoted and Stanford doors and resources and they came out with a peer
reviewed study that shows how New York state could get off of all fossil fuels,
all fossil fuels for all purposes,
transportation,
everything.
And that work is@thewebsitecalledthesolutionsproject.org.
You can see for every state they've done a map for every state,
how to get off of all oil,
coal and natural gas.
And there's an invite in massive amounts of public transportation to people who
have the same freedom to talking about electric cars.
You're talking about,
um,
fuel cells.
You're talking about a technology that exists today.
So it's,
it's a question of doing the transfer.
Um,
and what's really interesting is you save billions of dollars in healthcare
costs because we don't realize it,
but you're breathing in fossil fuel exhaust all the time and that causes huge
amounts of death and illness in the United States.
So,
um,
I mean if you could pull it up solutions project,
I don't have it in front of me,
but you save billions of dollars per state in avoided mortality costs.
And that's just one benefit.
I read a study recently that was talking about people that live in,
in urban environments live 10 years less than people that live in suburbs or in
rural areas just because of air quality.
Yeah.
And when Tom too,
not just the death rate,
but it's also birth defects and other things like,
um,
brake dust.
There's a lot of things that people aren't thinking about.
Brake dust is huge apparently in cities.
Like when you clean your car and you noticed that black stuff around your wheel,
it doesn't just stick to your fucking wheels.
That stuff gets in the air.
And if you're in like New York City to us,
right.
I don't,
I don't think it's as best as,
I don't think breakdown.
I mean,
I,
I'm not,
I'm not an expert on it.
I don't know what me,
man,
that final brake dust,
the fuck brake dust and made out of Jamie.
But,
um,
when you,
when you look at New York City for example,
and you see just fucking hundreds of thousands of cabs back and forth,
stop and go traffic,
they're just breaking constantly breaking,
kinda that stuff creates,
it obviously creates dust that gets on the wheels,
but it also gets in the air and shit is our production studio was right next to
the BQE.
I think about this a lot.
Oh,
it's cause it's so bad for you,
man.
I'm queens expressway.
Why don't you guys go to the suburbs somewhere?
Well mean I,
I live
there.
I live at least half the time in my house in Pennsylvania,
which is where,
you know where it all started,
right?
Yeah.
No,
I mean like fucked up is that area now.
It's beautiful.
It's nothing.
We won.
You want told anyone so no one.
And we wanted the Delaware River Basin in two 2013.
Um,
we want to political moratorium at the Delaware River is,
and the Dell and the New York City watershed is this interconnected watershed
system that brings water to 15 million people in New York City and Philadelphia
and southern New Jersey.
It's a pristine watershed.
It's one of the last pristine rivers like that on earth.
And the Delaware River basin is,
since it's a border,
is the border between New York and Pennsylvania,
between Pennsylvania and jersey,
the the river basin.
The river itself is controlled by this five member body,
the governors of New York,
Pennsylvania,
Delaware and New York,
Delaware and New Jersey.
And a representative from the federal government in 2011 we campaigned hard to
make sure that they,
they didn't pass regulations.
We won that fight when Delaware and New York both said,
we're unsure about this.
The Republican Governors of Pennsylvania and New Jersey,
Chris Christie and Tom Corbett wanted to frack the world's largest unfiltered
water supply.
They were like,
we don't care.
Um,
but we managed to create enough information going towards the Democrats,
um,
that they paused.
Now that meant we had a political moratorium in 2013 about 10 days after gassing
and two came out.
Um,
in my area,
there were a hundred thousand acres leased by the oil and gas industry.
They canceled the leases.
Now that was a day like I've never experienced like to realize that they just
left a hundred thousand acres worth of leads and I was surrounded by people who
at least we had 20 acres,
you know,
and my,
all my neighbors,
a lot of my neighbors had had least,
um,
you know,
and that was an amazing day when the oil and gas company just said,
we're out of here.
Um,
now what added to that New York state just passed this band?
It's a ban on primetime volume hydraulic fracturing,
which means that their vote on the Delaware River Basin Commission will
permanently be no right until that band has overturned.
If it were to ever be overturned,
I don't think it will be because the conditions under which that bag was created
are very complicated.
Like you had a six year environmental impact study,
you had a two year health review.
The health review says something very interesting and unusual and says that the
oil and gas industry now has to prove that they're safe.
That's a reversal of the burden of proof.
What would it normally is,
is the citizens were being contaminated,
have to prove that they were made ill or their water was contaminated air.
That's a very hard thing for individual citizens to do.
Scientists have to do that.
Universities have to do that,
labs have to do that.
It's extremely costly.
So the fact that that New York state has just said,
no,
actually oil and gas industry,
you guys are the ones who have to prove it.
You're safe when there's this huge preponderance of evidence that they're not
safe,
that they can never be safe,
that they're injecting chemicals into the ground and into the air.
So that's a huge thing.
So,
um,
the Delaware River basin is a national treasure.
You know,
it's an amazing place.
The Catskills go visit if you ever had no,
I've been there.
Yeah.
My parents used to live in Pennsylvania.
Okay.
Yeah.
So I've been there.
It's gorgeous.
I was inviting the listeners too.
Oh yeah,
you should go.
Yeah.
It's,
no,
it's gorgeous that,
that part of the world is amazing.
The reason why everybody used to go vacation in the Catskills.
Sure.
Fantastic.
I mean it's a lot of summer camps.
Yeah.
It gives you this reset,
you know,
and just get out into nature and you see what it's like.
Again,
the,
is there's any sort of method or is there any sort of preparation for cleanup
for these things?
Is there,
if they ever come up with a way to remove these,
uh,
like these areas that have been contaminated to remove the contaminants from the
water and the wells?
Well,
but the way this has been described to me,
um,
is under the ground,
right?
If you have a fracking leak or a benzene leak under the ground,
this is extremely hard to clean.
You can treat the water once it comes to the surface,
but getting the contaminants that are stuck to particles within the aquifers,
almost every scientist or every scientist I've ever said is,
it's almost ver,
it's virtually impossible.
So once you fuck it up,
if that's the,
the real problem right now with all this stuff,
it's not just fracking wells,
but it's also injection wells.
We do a lot of waste injection in America.
What does that mean?
We inject,
um,
toxic waste into the ground.
And we have been doing this for decades to just to get rid of it,
to get rid of it.
So like Nevada does with nuclear waste,
they just sort of theory several decades ago was if we inject it deep enough,
we'll never see it again because water aquifers are generally between 400 and
1200 feet.
They're pretty shallow.
These deep injection wells can be 10,000 feet deep,
right?
But what we're discovering,
and there's an a really jarring scientific American article about this,
um,
by a guy named Abrahm Lustgarten who was also investigating fracking.
Oh,
we worked on a lot of these things,
not together,
but on parallel tracks for years.
Um,
shows that,
well,
whoops,
we made a mistake.
There are,
you know,
Artesian Springs,
there are hot springs that,
that water travels under the ground and we've been injecting all sorts of toxic
waste,
not just the oil and gas industry,
although that is one of the bigger shares of this injection process,
right?
Produced water,
all these chemical,
um,
you know,
influenced or infused waters and,
but just from the chemists,
chemical industry,
the energy industry you're using when you have liquid,
toxic ways,
there are places all over the United States where you can just inject it into
the ground.
The problem is that those injection wells are leaking,
um,
at rates higher
even than the oil and gas wells.
They leak it to surface that they break down 10,000 feet and they get to the
surface.
Yeah,
that's what they're sharing.
That's what they're saying.
That this one EPA scientist was bonkers.
He,
in this article,
he said,
you know,
look,
this has been,
this is a terrible policy.
We're going to discover that all of our groundwater's polluted between now and a
hundred years from now.
So it's sort of the environmental equivalent to picking up the carpet and
sweeping shit under the rug.
Kind of,
except that comes right through the carpet and starts kind of carpet after
awhile.
It's like in poltergeist when they may be old,
the whole subdivision onto the and the Indian burial ground in the grave start
coming up through the suburban basement.
That's,
that's the,
that's like the metaphorical equivalent.
Um,
but you know,
look,
it doesn't even take hiding this stuff underground.
We are distanced from natural environments to a great degree and that we miss a
lot of this.
You know,
there is no agency for reporting spills,
onshore oil and gas bills in America,
but energy wire,
a good,
another amazing reporter named Mike Sora.
Han Did ran all these records for one year,
2012.
What did he found by plumbing?
The depths of state agencies,
records and all this kind of stuff was that there were 6,000 oil and gas bills
onshore in the United States in 2012 alone spilling more oil,
gas of wastewater and uh,
other fracking fluids and stuff.
Um,
they spilled 16 million gallons,
which was five,
four more gallons,
4 million more gallons than the entire Exxon Valdez spill.
And when you're unsure now as people are people noticing this?
I mean,
they probably are where they are at.
Is it being reported in the media?
Not a lot.
It wasn't a groundbreaking story from me.
It's astonishing to know that we had 6,000 oil and gas bills in 2012 spilling
more oil,
gas and waste water by a third.
Then the Exxon Valdez spill.
It's mind boggling.
So we're,
we're in a state where we're kind of distanced from how this actually all
affects the,
the natural systems that keep us alive.
Um,
and you know,
what's,
uh,
always amazing,
wonderful to me about going home after being on tour or being on a shoot or
something,
is that I go home and have confidence in the water.
Like I know,
I know what it kind of tastes like.
I know that it's in good shape.
I know that by and large it's not going to be contaminated.
And that is something that in the northeast of the United States is
extraordinarily precious resource and has a price tag on it for New York City.
Um,
it's,
you know,
worth billions and billions and billions of dollars per year to have that
pristine watershed in New York City tries to protect it.
And that is to a large degree why this fracking fight has gone all over and has
become such a huge thing in the media.
So,
correct me if I'm wrong,
but I think your idea is by,
by
doing this and what you've sort of gained from exploring this and,
and creating these documentaries is,
is this argument that we can't keep going the way we're going.
There is no way there's no,
we eventually will pollute everything and that there has to be some sort of
acknowledgement and recognition to this.
And some steps have to be taken and there's a huge blow back or push back from
that,
from the people that are extracting money by doing things the way they are.
And I think that's one of the things that people are arguing that our pro
fracking,
even people that aren't even in the industry,
there are those folks that tend to leave to lean towards conservative ideas
cause they go,
hey,
we need jobs.
Hey,
we need,
you know,
industry.
It's good for business and what you're saying I think,
and I think it's pretty hard to argue that ultimately if we keep doing what
we're doing,
pumping shit into the ground and fracking and you know,
all the waste it's getting into the oceans.
Like ultimately we've only been doing this for a couple of hundred years.
If you go back less,
yeah,
less.
But let's be really conservative.
Let's say 200 years,
200 years ago there was so much less pollution,
so much less waste.
There was no nuclear waste.
There was,
you know,
no fracking,
there was the oil wells that existed where you,
it was a totally different sort of a setup than we have today.
The things that they're doing now with these offshore oil rigs like Jesus
fucking Christ,
like the amount of waste,
the amount of actual pollutants that get into environments,
the,
the things that we're doing in these third world countries where they just go in
and,
and all that economic hitman shit where they take over these environments and
you know,
and give these people loans that they can't possibly pay back and then,
well we will just extract your resources then won't they set up this credit
system that is impossible to sustain and then they use it as just sort of a
method to get in and start extracting at a certain point in time that it's got
fuck up everything.
Like if it goes on another 200 years or another 500 years,
how much longer can it be done to deny that there is some sort of a process in,
in,
in place that has to be mitigated,
that has to be slowed down seems kind of crazy.
Yeah.
I have to realize that.
I mean,
we don't,
uh,
yeah.
You're,
you're going to have a epidemic of health problems.
Isn't it crazy that a guy like you,
you just a regular dude makes a,
a documentary and it's one of the leading voices.
I think it's surprising.
It's very sad.
But I feel like I had no choice.
You know,
it felt like it was a life and death issue to me.
And I think that's why we're seeing so many victories.
I mean this is astonishing what's happened.
A grassroots movement kept the oil,
the most powerful corporations in the history of money out of an entire state of
New York,
out of France,
out of the Netherlands.
Oh,
out of huge sections of Australia.
I would have a lot of South Africa.
I mean we're racking up win after win after win.
The reason is because people are trying,
I mean we're also losing a lot of places,
no question like say,
I mean that we're winning anywhere is kind of incredible.
But it's because I think people understand this as a life or death issue and,
and it's not that big of a leap.
And this is the point of all this new thoughts.
Like I'm working on this new film,
which is not fracking.
It's about climate change.
It's about how people fight in general and,
and it's about values,
but it's not that big of a leap to go,
oh,
you know what?
I don't want a fracking.
Well my backyard.
But even if I win and I don't have the fracking wells in my backyard in 20 years
from climate change,
I could lose everything I love about my backyard.
So this can't just be about my own place.
There's got to be all about all over the place.
And it all of a sudden everyone's on the front line because when you,
when you take into account that you have fracking in 34 states,
right?
Proposed for huge amounts of area,
and then you take into account,
well,
if you look at some of the maps on sea level rise,
you lose like all of Florida.
You lose most of our coastal cities on the east coast,
right?
Those people are on the front line.
If you look at the keystone XL pipeline running through the middle of the
country,
those people are on the front line.
If you look at the people who are fighting Tar Sands Development in Utah or
mountain top removal and long one wall mining in Appalachia or fracking in
California for that matter.
Um,
you know,
all of these things do start to add up and become one fight.
And we have,
um,
an amazing,
a convergence of purpose.
I think,
you know,
when you look at people who are in the fracking movement,
look at people who are in the climate change movement,
looking at people who are fighting Cole,
um,
or people who are basically trying to deal with health like public health,
like what you're talking about in terms of pollution standards in cities.
Um,
these things are adding up.
Uh,
and the,
the fight for,
I think social and economic and equality are bound together.
Um,
you know,
there was an a brilliant,
a piece that I just read about,
um,
Eric Gardner and I think it was in Salon and why environmentalist should be
interested in the fact that Eric Gardner was killed by a police in New York
City.
Well,
he had asthma.
Asthma is a consequence of inner city black people living in impoverished,
bad environmental conditions.
When you look at the black neighborhoods that are near coal fire power plants or
in bad you have do you have asthma rates that are much higher than in white
neighborhoods,
which are more affluent.
These things are tied together.
So what we're seeing when I'm,
when I look out and go,
okay,
yeah you're right,
we have a crisis.
The fracking might be,
my might've been my way into understanding this crisis or someone else's
might've been climate.
Someone else's might've been how the Rockaways were submerged under Hurricane
Sandy.
Someone else's might've been Eric Garner's death and going,
Oh wow,
this man might have survived had he not had asthma,
had that not been an environmental indicator for people in rural communities of
color.
I mean urban communities of color.
So yeah,
there's a thing that's,
that's starting to wake up here and I'm,
it's very exciting to watch.
So cause once you're inside of it,
it's like a different system.
You know,
you're,
you have a lot of mutual support,
like people who were in the Anti fracking movement.
If the do you know,
you meet somebody who's from Wyoming or from South America or from California or
New York,
you're immediately in a sort of kinship situation where now your brothers,
your family,
your,
your friends were working on this.
We're working on trying to fix this problem and you see a different system of
values start to get engaged.
Um,
and recently just down in the Amazon with these incredible Quichua of people and
in places we're part of the Amazon.
While I was in two places,
I was in the Peruvian Amazon,
um,
along the [inaudible] river where you,
we saw devastating oil spills in the middle of the jungle just from pipeline
ruptures.
And then another place called,
sorry,
Yakut in Ecuador,
which had actually successfully fought off the oil and gas industry and one
reparations from them,
uh,
and got rid of them.
So we kind of like went to the Pennsylvania of the Amazon,
which,
and to the New York.
Um,
and,
uh,
I read a paper,
it interestingly,
uh,
by a guy in,
I'm in Massachusetts,
peer reviewed scientific paper,
which showed that indigenous values protecting the forest protecting
deforestation are actually something that should be rewarded financially because
they're the ones who are protecting the earth from climate change.
So their values of respecting the forest,
not cutting it down,
all of these kinds of things actually has a current price tag on it that says,
you know,
these people are keeping carbon dioxide out of the atmosphere.
These people are,
um,
cause the Amazon without the Amazon we'd be screwed.
You know,
like we,
we,
the Amazon breathes in so much of the carbon dioxide that we export and breathes
it back out into the world as oxygen.
If you've seen an inconvenient truth,
you see Al Gore's line that staggers up and down.
That's because summertime in the Amazon breeds in all of our,
uh,
CO2,
um,
and brings it back out as oxygen.
So these people are actually protecting when simply because of the value system
are protecting us in the way that we're doing things.
So there is something to be gained from looking at,
um,
now I'm not saying you got to live in the middle of the jungle and he barks
bugs,
lizards and leaves.
And not saying that,
but that there is something of a conversation that has to happen and it's
happening right now between,
you know,
what do we really,
what really makes you feel,
you know,
what is really the point,
right?
Is it just to consume as much as we possibly can and burn up all these resources
and live in this incredibly wasteful way?
Or is or,
or do we have to start to have a conversation about what does all this mean?
What are we doing as life on the planet and can we move towards more sustainable
ways of being?
And the science and the economics from every standpoint says,
absolutely,
we have to phase out oil and gas.
And by the way,
the great thing about this is we can,
and if we actually want to continue to live in a democracy,
which is our values,
right?
We have to,
we have no choice because oil and gas is currently destroying our ability to
have demo democracy in America.
And so by the way,
is the banking industry,
um,
you know,
there was this study that too much influence,
too much power.
Well,
I mean,
Princeton University,
Princeton University did a peer reviewed study that asked this kind of naive
question,
hmm,
what form of government does America actually have?
And they did all this research and looked at all these public policy questions
and they came back with a result.
Lo and behold,
America is not a democracy.
America isn't oligarchy currently,
which is why you can have 90% of people want,
you know,
background checks for people buying AK 47 [inaudible] and we don't get it.
And 80% of people can,
um,
you know,
want,
uh,
you know,
a minimum wage hike and we don't get it.
Or 75% of people want Kurt curtailing of global greenhouse gas emissions and we
don't get it.
It's because we're not in a democracy that actually are voting.
And our opinions don't have an influence on the things that mattered the most to
us right now.
Unless you're an oligarch,
unless you have $1 billion and you can play that game.
So the answer to what form of government America has right now is not a
democracy,
which means our democracy has been destroyed by those people who are currently
taking it away from us.
And if we want to have those democratic values,
we have to start to take back the power,
which means you have to start to organize and you have to do all the things that
happens when you know we don't have democracy anymore.
And if you look back in history,
well,
could you really say that America was a democracy when black people couldn't
vote,
when women couldn't vote,
you know?
Um,
no.
In fact,
looking back at American history,
American wasn't a democracy most of the time it was a democracy of some.
But Ma,
Ma most and right now that some is getting smaller and smaller and smaller to
the 1% who have control of the reins of power.
And if we want to take that stuff back,
then you have to start to realize that you have to do every single thing that
all of those very potent social movements have done throughout history.
What did black people do to,
to,
to fight everything?
We made movies.
He made protests,
we did lobbying,
we created organizations.
Um,
we fought,
uh,
in,
in all the creative ways made films,
made a cold culture of resistance.
Um,
if you're talking about the women's movement,
if you're talking about the movement of black people and the same thing is
happening.
I,
I say I see this in the current crisis,
whether your insurance point is occupied,
Wall Street is looking at banking and your entrance point is environmentalism.
Um,
your entrance point could be public health,
your entrance point,
um,
could be gun control.
You know,
you're starting to see people really do that organizing in democratic work.
And what's amazing to me is that that means democracy is alive and well in
America.
It's working too to some degree and we're seeing that this is our tools,
our culture,
our tools or information or tools are radio shows like this,
you know,
to,
to talk about where we need to go as a society because currently it's not just
the environment that is being destroyed,
contaminated and havoc as being wrought upon it is our system of government.
Yeah.
I think that what we're dealing with now,
what we're dealing with now is the amount of information that we can get on a
regular basis is so far above and beyond anything that's ever existed in human
history that these old systems that were in place where they kind of deny facts
or distort truths or keep extracting money and keep certain certain structures,
influential structures in place there,
they're slowly but surely being exposed.
And ultimately I,
I mean I really,
I'm a huge fan of technology and when I follow technological trends and you pay
attention to these transhumanists and futurists and you look at what they're
projecting as far as like the next few decades,
there's gonna come a point in time where we were literally going to be able to
read each other's minds and you're,
you're going to have full disclosure of virtually everything that everyone does.
That's kind of scary.
It's terrifying.
But in a,
in a,
in a sense it's not because I mean it's terrifying because we value privacy.
We valued the idea that we can,
but privacy also equals secrecy when it comes to corporations and that's one of
the things that they're doing.
And the,
the,
even,
even though we know how much influence oil and gas companies have banking
industry has on politics and lobbyists,
we know all that.
We only know it in this sort of kind of peripheral sense.
You've got to kind of really dig deep to find out the actual facts and what the
fuck has the time to do the research.
Like we were talking about the seven year study that New York state,
it's exhaustive study that they had to do.
I mean that's a little Dodick God damn work.
And these people had to be hired to do that.
It had to be their job.
That's what they did.
Yeah,
they were.
It was a functioning democracy,
a lot of digging,
a lot of fucking digging.
Part of that,
part of that though was entered,
was tapping into collective willpower and collective research because part of
the study in New York was public comments,
public hearings.
Right.
So the people,
I,
I w you had two minutes,
you get went and got up in front of the department,
environmental conservation and you said your two minutes,
you know,
and EPA did the same thing when they did their scoping process on fracking.
So it wasn't just,
um,
government people getting paid.
It was also public participation,
which meant that it was a democratic process that was at work there.
We are collectively so much smarter than any one of us and so much more
motivated than any one of us.
So when you're doing,
I'm going early on and I'm very naive days of,
of taping stuff for uh,
for whatever I was making or doesn't even know if it was a whole film at that
point.
Six hours of public testimony do two minutes
per person,
you know,
and just going on and on and on.
But this is what ended up actually creating the fracking ban because in each one
of these environmental review periods,
there were a chance for the public to comment the most,
um,
uh,
public comments that had ever been recorded.
Pre fracking on one of these environmental impact studies was a thousand.
And in the first fracking review,
I think it was 2009,
they submitted 13,000 public comments.
In his second review,
they submitted 74,000 public comments.
And in the final review they submitted,
or I've saved they,
but I mean,
the movement in New York submitted 204,000 public comments on an environmental
impact study.
Now for the Dec to do its job,
it's required by law to respond to every one of those
200,000 to 4,000.
Yeah.
Which means that that democratic process,
yeah,
it delayed the review by years and years,
which is part of the point,
but it also meant that this issue was so important to people that they actually
did public comments on a environmental impact study and went out.
This is like way more than like when move on sends you a petition petitioner,
you just click yes,
this is like doing your homework and getting out and doing all those kinds of
things.
Um,
you know,
so,
so that was really significant.
But that was a democratic process.
That was New York sang to its citizens.
We don't really know what this process is.
What are your concerns and how do we address them?
It's the opposite of what Pennsylvania did.
It's the opposite of what a lot of Ohio did.
Um,
oh,
they just opened the door.
I said,
all right,
come on in.
You want to frack.
Go.
What's the worst offenders when it comes to the allowing of fracking,
the allowing of environmentally damaging extraction methods?
Well,
I mean you just,
South Dakota's off the charts,
right?
Dakota,
North Dakota,
North Dakota.
Bakken shale is a disaster area.
They're going crazy.
I was just up there and over the summer it is one of the worst.
I mean,
you've got flaring,
frack pits,
emissions,
um,
criminals,
the Wazoo from all over the country on a criminal background.
Checks get a job,
make a hundred grand in a year,
dig holes,
light him on fire.
A lot of 'em mad max.
No,
but actually there are reports aren't food and Water Watch did a report on
social costs and found that all of these indicators,
social costs,
indicators go up in fracking areas,
truck traffic,
socially transmitted diseases,
domestic violence,
arrests,
you know,
everything that where you're going to have a dislocated young male population
living in camps in these places.
Those kinds of things go up and you're right,
there weren't any background checks and you had sex offenders and had all this
kinds of stuff.
It sounds like a party they did bringing in people from all over the country,
aren't they?
The,
when you go to the boxes,
you can see the Bakken shale from space.
NASA was like,
wait a minute.
Did we built?
It's brighter than Chicago.
It was brighter than Chicago.
Brighter than Minneapolis from space because they're flaring off.
Guess what?
The place that the product that tyrannized my area of Pennsylvania natural gas
is being wasted and flared off and burned off on all these oil wells in the
Bakken shale because they have no method for transporting natural gas.
Why is that?
Well,
when you're doing this drilling,
you're getting both oil and gas.
Right now.
Oil is worth something.
The gas isn't worth as much.
Dry Gas right now on the market is very low,
so they're not capturing the gas at all.
So when you drill an oil well,
you're going to get some part of it,
which is oil.
And another huge part of it,
which is the gas,
the gas on the site will be burned off first of all,
because it's exploding at the photos.
So you have like,
oh,
it's behind.
Yeah,
there you go.
Take a buck and family formation.
So that's all that means that every like 500 feet,
there's a huge natural gas fire in the middle of a field that's enormous.
And that is fucking crazy.
It is bigger,
bigger than Minneapolis.
Yeah.
That's bigger than Chicago.
But NASA was like,
wait a minute,
what is that?
And I just went up there,
this is going to be in the new film.
Um,
and,
and we saw not only these huge flare stacks,
but we saw,
um,
uh,
through a flir camera,
which is this camera that captures gas,
that raw methane,
even though they're burning it all off,
it's escaping from a lot of the infrastructure up there.
So there's always people breeding that shit in.
So the massive fucking oh,
breathing that shit.
I've seen pictures of workers,
there's FRAC sand,
right?
So they,
they,
when they inject the water and the chemicals into the gas wells to,
they need fresh sand to,
to keep the,
it's a proppant.
It keeps opening the cracks.
Frac sand is actually made of Silica Silica.
It gives you silicosis.
It's really deadly lung disease.
Um,
I've,
I've seen these dudes,
so it's call this like frac sand spill or a spill off sand like um,
the [inaudible] beach and like hanging out on the frac sand,
like swimming in it,
making jokes and stuff like this.
What these workers have no idea.
I'm just,
well there's a new piece that we just,
um,
I just did on workers in the oil and gas industry and we don't know where it's
going to land yet and we've seen a face bureau wants it and maybe there are
other channels that want it,
but a lot of these workers are not told what their further handling and there's
an epidemic of really serious illnesses among the fracking workers,
whether they're in Pennsylvania or in the Bakken shale or in New Orleans or
wherever.
And I mean Louisiana ones,
the BP oil spill cleanup people they brought in prisoners,
right?
They were also told that they weren't allowed to wear a respirator.
Masks and all sorts of stuff.
That is it.
I mean like inhaling,
volatile organic compounds is bad for you.
It gives you headaches,
it can give you a peripheral neuropathy.
It can also give you longterm effects.
Um,
the great,
uh,
Theo Colborn,
who just passed away a couple of weeks ago,
who was one of my teachers,
um,
she was in her late eighties.
She discovered all the fracking chemicals.
Um,
she started off talking to workers and the workers would come to her and say,
do you know anything about these chemicals?
These,
she's,
Oh,
yes,
I do.
And she at her website,
Tedx,
the endocrine disruption exchange,
t e d [inaudible] dot org.
You can see,
um,
uh,
all of the fracking chemicals and their corresponding health effects.
Okay.
So you've got damage to every system in the,
in the body.
Um,
uh,
from,
you know,
uh,
respiratory to,
um,
uh,
reproductive too,
you know,
cancer to,
um,
all sorts of things.
And you can look at the list there,
but onsite,
these workers are not told that they're handling toxic chemicals.
These workers are not told that they're drilling into formations that are
radioactive.
These workers are not told,
don't get that stuff on your clothes.
Um,
don't expose your hands to it.
Don't,
you know,
breathe it in.
They're not given these kinds of protections on.
Um,
currently if you're working in the oil and gas industry,
the fatality rate is seven times the national average for other industries.
So you,
some times you have a lot of guys too.
Well disease or no,
most of that stuff is all longterm.
This is immediate and fatalities or are a lot of accidents.
Um,
gas and oil wells explode.
Uh,
but the majority is,
um,
truck accidents and heavy equipment accidents because truck drivers in the oil
and gas fields are not subject to the same truck driving laws.
I mean,
I know I keep going on and on about how awful is it,
but it's all true.
Truck driving laws in the United States say you can't drive,
I think it's more than 12 hours.
Um,
but if you're an oil field truck driver,
there's something called oil field exempt,
you're oilfield exempt,
which means you can travel six hours to get to your oil.
Well,
but let's say the load isn't ready there yet.
So you can sit on location for six hours and then still have to drive another
six hours.
And now or,
and so you can sit on different locations and not,
that doesn't count.
So it was one worker put it to me.
You're 25 hours into a 24 hour day.
And guess what?
You're driving a big rig around in western Pa perhaps or North Dakota.
It's full of toxic fluid in the back of your thing.
And then you're so tired that you drive off the road and into a creek and that's
how you have a big spill or you're so tired that you flip your truck onto
somebody's vehicle.
As was when it happened to a,
uh,
a good friend of mines,
close friend,
uh,
um,
the truck flipped over,
uh,
killed the person in the driver's seat and the person in the passenger seat was
not killed.
I mean,
you've seen traffic accidents on the rise.
Um,
and so there's a great article and interveners,
uh,
um,
drilling down series in the New York Times about truck truck accidents and the
piece that we're doing,
um,
uh,
talks about the chemicals and the workers that are exposed to chemicals with
several workers who were made very ill on the,
on the job site by being exposed to,
they're,
they're told to squeegee off the top of the chemical that's on the top of the
well pad site and then put it into their trucks and they get it all over
themselves.
And then other,
um,
workers are killed because the sites are not safe.
So this is a new piece that we,
I hope will be coming out in the next month or two,
um,
about the work in the gas fields.
Okay.
That the,
the driving thing is terrifying to me because you're on the road right next to
him.
You see those guys driving trucks and everybody's heard the stories about guys,
I'm truck driver math.
And they mean they make more money if they can get there quicker.
So they've put regulations in to make sure that drivers are not allowed to drive
certain hours.
But you always hear about people violating those.
Like the guy that uh,
gotten that car accident that killed Tracy Morgan's friend and hurt him.
The Guy who was driving that truck for a Walmart,
is that what it was?
Yeah.
Was it Walmart?
I mean that guy was driving more than the limit when more than one it was
supposed to do and he fell asleep,
fell asleep and crashed into their limo,
um,
asleep behind the wheel.
When you're driving a huge oil and gas truck truck,
common and perilous situation in these fracking areas.
And it's one of the things exemption,
I think it happened in the 60s where they,
where they argued that they needed more flexibility.
I mean,
look,
you look into every single environmental law that's on the books right now I'm
in America,
there are attempts or full out exemptions.
The oil and gas in the fracking industry is exempt from the safe drinking water
act.
The safe drinking water act is a primary public health protection law for our
groundwater.
Right.
It says,
if you're going to inject toxic material under the ground,
you need a permit from EPA or you need to ask if you need a permit.
Fracking in 2005 was made explicitly exempt from the safe drinking water act in
the 2005 energy bill,
which was Dick Cheney's a project.
Um,
it was their number one thing that they were after says to,
to this huge fracking explosion.
Um,
and uh,
they're currently still exempt from the safe drinking water act.
In fact,
there are exemptions for the oil and gas industry from most of our major
environmental laws.
The clean water act,
which is about surface water,
the safe,
uh,
the clean air act,
which is,
uh,
what,
Obama Administration is choosing to enforce new rules.
Um,
the Super Fund Act,
the superfund act is the like,
uh,
a fund that oil and gas was supposed to pay into,
to do environmental cleanup,
right?
So that was a signed in I think 1980 by Jimmy Carter in 1979.
And the only reason we have a superfund act is because there was a little horse
trading.
And Congress that to get the superfund to act passed,
guess what they did?
They suspended environmental impact studies in the Gulf of Mexico for offshore
drilling.
So that's why you have this huge amount of offshore drilling on the Gulf of
Mexico and not for example in the Atlantic coast,
cause they don't have to do an environmental impact study down there.
Why?
Because they want it to pass the Super Fun to do toxic cleanup onshore in
America.
Now
30 years for 35 years later,
they oil and gas industry has completely weaseled out of their obligations to
pay into the Super Fund to act.
So they're exempt from the super fund regulations.
Um,
for fracking and every single fracking well pad site would be considered a super
fund site because there's not much,
how does it work?
Does that continuing go as Princeton?
And they still get subsidized as well,
which is even crazier.
Oh well this is what I'm trying to explain here.
I'm not talking about abstract concepts are abstract influence.
You can trace these things really clearly.
You can see the,
you know,
if you,
if you read your history,
in fact,
a lot of this stuff is in the presidential report on the deep water horizon
spill.
It's a fascinating document.
It reads kind of like a spy novel.
You can,
you know,
like the,
the,
the rig explodes.
People jump off into the world,
but you're also get the history right there of how all this stuff happened.
And one of the conclusions in that presidential report was that the oil and gas
industry was in fact two big,
more powerful than any branch of government that ever tried to regulate it.
So what you're seeing right now is that they're not more powerful,
however,
then citizens working together.
And this is what keep campaigning,
keeps saying that the answer here is the grassroots.
The answer here is us working together,
um,
as a grassroots movement.
And you've seen this in California.
Californians against fracking was started I think when we,
we,
we did the press conference kickoff here in,
um,
in La and a 2013.
Um,
and we've started a new thing called solutions grassroots,
which is,
you know,
the solutions project did the science on how to do,
uh,
renewable energy solutions.
Grassroots is actually putting the tools to develop renewable energy at a
grassroots level in the people's hands.
So at our website,
which is solutions grassroots.com,
and we're doing a solutions grassroots tour,
we're going town to town to build renewable energy resources at a democratic
level.
So when you go into a town,
well,
we do like a presentation,
whether it's,
we actually had a play going for a,
we sometimes do concerts,
we do talks.
Um,
and then we go into the citizenship and say,
look,
do you want solar on your roof?
Here are these companies that will do it.
Do you want to buy locally sourced wind power?
Well,
here's how you can do it in certain states,
right?
Do you want to create,
uh,
an energy collective in your town?
Here's the resources for it.
So it's a lot of times it's just giving people information right then and there
and saying,
you know,
getting people riled up and excited and giving them the support to do it.
So,
um,
we're going to do about a 40 city tour of solutions grassroots in New York state
in February and March.
So we'll do like three or four towns a day.
Um,
and I'll,
I'll be doing that with Zephyr Teachout who was incredibly popular,
um,
candidate for governor who won 35% of the vote against Andrew Cuomo and his last
election.
Um,
and a number of
musical guests.
I think we're going to be doing that in February and March.
We'd love to do the solutions grassroots tour in California,
um,
love to do it in other states.
So you can go to solutions,
grassroots.com.
You can sign up there,
you can,
there,
there are links that directly you can buy solar.
Uh,
you can buy wind power,
you can do all that at a consumer level.
But more importantly,
what we're trying to do with solutions grassroots is getting grassroots,
um,
energy movement towards,
getting ourselves off fossil fuels.
Because you know this,
even though like you can map this out at Stanford and you have these great,
amazing celebrities all talking about renewable energy,
the people have to get it done.
We have to get it done.
We have to say,
you know what?
I don't want to buy oil and gas and coal to heat my home to power my home
anymore.
I didn't want to do that anymore.
I want to get off of it.
You know.
Um,
some of the resources are very expensive,
like buying an electric car that's out of the range for a lot of people.
But getting solar on your roof actually is economic.
Um,
it makes sense.
Getting a buying locally sourced wind power is possible in a lot of states.
It's not in California,
I don't think,
but it is in New York state it,
there's a company called ethical electric that we have a link
to@ourwebsitesolutionsgrassroots.com.
Or you can just basically say,
you know what?
I'm going to buy wind power instead of buying electricity from coal or oil or
gas.
And um,
you know,
you've done a huge amount right there.
But the biggest thing that we've done in terms of all this stuff,
New York,
by stopping fracking kept the equivalent of 57 million cars off the road just by
keeping that stuff in the ground there.
And I think the equivalent of taking 72 coal fire power plants offline for a
year,
the movement is actually going to help solve these things.
Um,
so it's,
it's like how do you get people together?
Well,
we just get together.
We have a film screening.
There are a lot of great films on this stuff.
We have a tour,
we have a talk and you start organizing locally.
And while this is going on,
you still got North Dakota,
but it's just going off the rails.
You do.
But I have how much light environment,
mental impact is the burning of that you were getting into that,
but the burning of that natural gas.
Well,
I mean I don't,
I don't know.
I don't have direct figures for that.
But what,
what I do know is that's a lot of these new unconventional resources have to be
stopped.
So Bakken shale is actually unconventional oil.
It's shale gas,
it's fracked oil,
the tar sands for example,
in our,
in Canada,
which you mentioned the keystone XL pipeline.
This is another unconventional source.
So without a doubt we have to rule out unconventional new sources of these
fossil fuels.
Um,
and then we have to start to phase out the other ones.
But you know,
um,
do I have a direct figure for how much damage I don't on,
I don't have it in my head.
I just know that someone just did the math on the New York band and that you can
research.
I think it's an oil change international cause it website change international,
um,
or dirty energy.
money.com I think links to a dirty energy.
money.com is an amazing website where you can actually plug punch in your
senator or congressman or congresswoman and find out how much money they took
from the oil and gas lobby.
Um,
and where it came from.
but I think oil change or are,
I mean,
I might have it on my phone,
but there was an article I read recently about the Duke University pro fracking,
uh,
study that they put out and the influence that the oil industry had on that and
they traced it back to the money that was involved in oil industry that had
something to do with Duke University and then had an influence on the flat
fracking study.
Again,
the template,
again,
the template is the tobacco industry.
When you have these places like North Dakota where you know,
you don't,
you have so much momentum,
there's so much money,
so many people who have a vested financial interest in keeping it going and so
many people are benefiting from it.
Like,
how the fuck do you stop something like that.
Like how is it even possible to slow that monster down?
Um,
you know,
I have to believe in the same things that have worked over the last eight years
with the fracking movement.
And I have to believe in the things that have created social and economic change
in the past.
You know,
um,
I don't think there is any other answer then organizing,
mobilizing,
and that is,
you know,
um,
we can point to New York as this great example.
We can also point to the Obama campaign in 2008.
It's this incredible grassroots mobilization.
It's about neighbor talking to neighbor.
It's about canvassing.
It's about being involved at a local level.
I really think that that's the case.
Um,
I think you have to make more responsible energy decisions personally,
obviously.
Um,
and there are ways to do that and like gave the website out.
But I think the most important thing to do,
I mean,
you're going to have states which are very challenging.
in Florida right now,
the sunshine state,
it is illegal to have a home off the grid.
Yeah.
Isn't that hilarious?
It's like,
how'd that happen?
All the conservative people or government there decided that they wanted to keep
everyone totally addicted to oil and gas.
What the fuck?
I mean,
but the hilarious taken do that though.
Yeah.
I mean it's,
it's um,
you,
uh,
I think the,
the,
the good news is that you're seeing fracking really be a game changer.
Not In the way that the oil and gas industry thought it was.
They thought this was a game changer for their continued world domination.
I think it's a game changer for how we're going to start to change all of this
because there's so many people involved.
Well,
because it's so,
it's also the impact is so fucking devastating.
So it's so obvious.
You can see it and you can,
and you look at it,
you could look at it.
You do not want to live in one of these areas and that's about in line.
And you have enough people who are saying,
not in my backyard,
across the,
you have a movement,
but you have enough also know people like that are going to North Dakota because
of the money.
I mean,
they,
they're like,
fuck this.
You know,
I can make some money.
I can retire,
I can do this.
I could do that.
I can have a life for myself.
Give me that opportunity.
That oil is going to be more expensive than solar and wind at a certain point.
So it means that you get solar and wind ramped up.
Um,
you're going to be able to undercut them in the marketplace.
But what,
what one thing I have to tell you is these are creating conditions that are
created by the government.
If you invest $1 million in oil or coal or gas,
you get about three jobs,
3.8 jobs.
If you invest $1 million in wind and solar,
you get 9.5 and 9.8 jobs respectively.
So you get much more jobs out of doing renewable energy.
It's just the math.
I'm like,
that's not,
and by the way,
you would not do that job in the Bakken shale.
You are bathing in oil and fracking chemicals.
You are your job.
There is extraordinarily short lived,
not just in the Bakken shale.
We should particularly harsh conditions,
right?
Because you might be living in a trailer that's costing you a huge amount of
money per month with no you no running water and you know it's freezing there
and people die.
Just trying to go there and live there.
Um,
or you might be living in like a man camp,
you know,
like,
like Whoa,
really bad working conditions.
They're called man can camp.
You don't want to live in a man.
Good.
You don't want to live in Vancouver.
But what I'm saying is these jobs are not good for workers.
They're not good for the environment and at a certain point,
and Van Jones,
he says this in our worker piece,
I'm Van Jones as we,
you know,
like you could create jobs by chopping the heads off of small kittens if you,
when you could call it a judge,
they don't stop doing that.
It's a job.
But at a certain point you have to have a moral standard.
That is true.
Right.
That is an interesting thing like the creating of jobs,
but at what cost?
Like what?
When can you stop saying it's creating jobs and start saying that you're
profiting off of fucking up a spot forever like that where they're at right now
in North Dakota.
How long would it take to clean that up?
You can't just,
you can't just pass everything just because,
oh,
it's a job,
therefore we don't have to look at what the job is.
Can you put like a big Britta filter along the whole state?
And,
and the truth is that a lot of that land is,
um,
first nation's land.
Um,
you know,
and uh,
we met an amazing,
a kid who was,
I think it was 19 or 20,
his name was lance.
He was running for tribal council in the Bakken Shale.
And his whole plan was to implement wind.
Do you know that North Dakota is the windiest place on earth like UN in the
United States?
Not on earth like there,
it's been said 20 years ago or more,
that just three states,
North Dakota,
Kansas,
and Texas can provide all of America's energy needs with their wind resource for
all of them,
including the fleet of 300 million just from wind in three states,
North Dakota,
Kansas,
and Texas.
Would they have to cover the states in these stupid fucking windmills?
No,
no,
no.
And by the way,
a lot of those places,
our farmlands,
right,
which very,
very sparsely populated,
and you can actually do farming and wind at the same time.
You have a wind tower in the middle of the feminine and you don't know that.
We'll be fine.
You probably wouldn't even notice if your corner or whatever it was came from
where a wind farm was.
But if you were having a fracking pad in the middle of a farm with all those
toxic emissions,
um,
you'd probably be a little worried about what you were eating.
So essentially they could shut down those fracking sites that are fucking up
everything and then set up in those same places.
Wind towers that would provide more energy.
Um,
not just more energy in the moment,
but when you think about wind and solar,
you're tapping a resource that is unlimited,
unlimited,
completely sustainable forever.
Forever is a really crazy word when you think about energy,
because we always think about energy as finite oil,
gas.
It's got to run out.
Your gas is going to run out in your tank.
Think about wind.
Yeah,
it's,
you're not going to tap the wind.
You're not.
And when you think about where the resources at the offshore off of the North
Atlantic coast,
you,
um,
uh,
have an enormous wind resource in the North Atlantic.
So setting off offshore wind,
I mean,
you could have a,
all of the northeast powered by wind power,
um,
off of,
uh,
Long Island and they could be so far out that you would hardly even see them
from the beach.
Wow.
That's a,
that's a thing.
That future don't think about.
You think that's what it is.
You think wind or solar and wind?
Well,
it's both.
It's all of them.
It's distributed generation,
distributed generation of power.
So that we're not having,
we're not dependent.
I mean,
look,
you're going to have more superstorms.
The places on the Rockaways waste,
it's still had power were the ones that had solar.
You know,
you have these storms and all these things knock out the grid and then you have
big blackouts all over the place.
This is a bad system.
You're losing,
it's not efficient.
It's not close to its vulnerable when we're talking about offshore wind.
Absolutely.
In fact,
there's this study also by Mark Jacobson that suggests huge amounts of wind.
Offshore wind turbines actually dampen hurricane winds.
Um,
they slow down the winds and they dampen the storm surge.
So you are talking about building $30 billion wind walls in like a wind.
Uh,
I mean,
sorry seawalls around a lot of major cities like New York,
but you could build it as a wind farm instead.
Um,
and you actually make your money back.
Now it's an enormous amount of wind turbans,
70,000 wind turbines for something like this.
And they would say that you would lessen the storm surge,
for example,
for a Katrina or sandy by 50% or more.
Um,
but when you consider the fact that Pennsylvania projections 200,000 to 600,000
gas wells,
you know,
70,000 wind turbines sounded like quite so much anymore.
But this is the future.
We know that the future is going to be renewable energy.
We know that that's the,
that's the way it's going to go.
Um,
the question is,
will we be able to prevent oil and gas right now from a next era of
contamination and destruction?
So it's just the momentum of the system that's in place.
Yeah.
The amount of money that's involved,
the amount of influences from all [inaudible] and the amount of people that
depend upon those industries for jobs.
And so slowly sort of transitioning out of that.
Well,
we have to,
I mean there's,
there's,
there's simply,
there's a moral issue and an environmental and health imperative to doing so.
Um,
David,
if we do,
it's,
it's going to be really difficult to mitigate the damage that's already been
done.
For sure.
That's true.
And also,
um,
even if we do,
we're still going to experience a great deal of climate change warming.
Um,
it's going to be very difficult to reverse a lot of those effects co carbon
dioxide last hundreds of years in the atmosphere.
So we're going to have trouble.
It's going to be tough.
And that's why we need resilient values that are different than every man,
every woman for himself and every SUV for itself.
That's why when this,
when we're talking about fracking,
we're talking about global warming.
We're talking about a movement to try to change these things.
It can't simply be checked this box.
Now I have wind power on good.
We're in for some things that are going to be rough and they're going to require
us.
I mean,
they're rough now.
when you look at all the things that are happening,
um,
to greater pop proportion of our population in the United States,
we're out in the world are suffering from illness or suffering from a
disenfranchisement of one kind or another.
We have to start to move in a direction where we're,
um,
you know,
we're working together a bit more and there's some weird trends that we're
seeing here in California that really freaked me out.
Like the fact that we're in the worst drought of some point 1200 years,
some fucking crazy number.
They throw out 11 trillion gallons of water we would need to make up for the,
um,
the amount of drought we've had over the last three years,
just three years.
Like that's weird man.
And it makes you think like you're living in this place that doesn't have any
water coming in.
You've got to get all your water from somewhere else.
It's a double whammy to,
because you're,
you're the Colorado River,
which is supplying a lot of the south west is also dry getting,
getting running out of water.
Yeah.
They're having droughts in Colorado as well.
So you're,
you're talking about things that are getting,
you know,
uh,
worse.
And if,
if it look,
if it was up to Coca Cola,
they would just tell you every last drop.
I mean,
you know,
and,
but is that what we want?
I think what we need to do is figure out a way to take the salt out of the ocean
and that bitch is right.
There seems like a lot of water.
Like I,
I don't know.
But what I do know is that like without getting too strength,
too far down the path,
I think over and over again what we've seen work are social movements that are
built on neighbors and community ties working together.
Do you know anything about desalination plants or any of that shit?
I don't know.
It seems like something that could be done right.
I mean,
I know it can be done.
They've already heard that they built a car in Europe,
the breads out salt water.
Yes.
Yes they have.
Yeah.
That was pretty fascinating.
I want to,
how dope would that be?
Can go like,
it's like a lotus or something.
It's like as fast as fuck.
It's beautiful too.
So you know about,
yeah.
Yeah.
Well,
it's like these cars that they're coming out with,
these electric cars are really amazing and fascinating.
Like the Tesla,
all the stuff that Elon Musk is putting out.
He's got a new Tesla roadster that can go 400 miles now,
which is the new limit.
And that's pretty incredible.
Yeah,
they're really expensive.
Yeah.
They're very sense.
And,
and,
and um,
mark,
uh,
challenged.
Mark Rafflo challenged him to make one that's under $30,000,
I think,
and two in the next couple of years because that's the real barrier,
right?
I always charging,
I have to stay it.
Like when somebody gets up and like we do a lot of interactive,
you know,
whether it's speeches or public or screenings and Q and.
A,
there's always somebody who gets up and goes,
well I have solar panels on my roof and I have a Tesla and I'm always like,
and you're rich.
Right?
So these can't just be about individual solutions.
I mean I love,
I mean obviously you,
Elon Musk is like way making amazing stuff and he's showing the world that is
possible.
At the same time,
like these need to be affordable solutions for people.
Well,
right now,
you know,
what's the cheapest car you can get?
Like an economy car,
like a regular car.
Like you can get a car for 20 grand,
right?
Like really?
Yeah,
you can get a car for weight.
But I mean a new never had a car.
I've never bought a new car.
I don't know.
But if you bought a new car,
I like playing.
What's that?
13,000 probably for like a really,
well,
even if it's not shitty,
just doesn't have anything in it.
Just real base,
very small car without not a lot of horsepower,
skinny tires.
I bought a Camry hybrid 2007 for 11,008 life.
What do you know it was?
Wait,
what's wrong with that?
What do you have?
Just dry.
It's boring.
You know the,
the,
the beautiful thing about [inaudible],
it's not boring at all.
Camry hybrids.
Not Boring at all.
Who are you and almost scarfs from another planet and almost slid off the road
lecture.
Well,
you know it's not going to split off the road.
That's why it's not boring.
It doesn't handle well.
No,
it makes me exciting cause he want to know what you want to know.
What's,
what's not boring,
but where you drive it.
Where are you driving or are you driving it?
Well,
I mean you won't off roading.
Your Camry hybrid.
No,
dude,
when I tried to say it upset about,
I don't know what you're saying,
it's not boring,
but you're not giving me any reasons why it's not boring.
The car doesn't make it boring.
What you doing with your life is what makes it boring or not.
I'm sorry.
That's total nonsense to say,
my life is more exciting because I have exciting car.
That's,
no,
I'm not the one that makes sense.
Well that's what you do with your life matters.
You don't need a car to have an exciting life.
Very well what I'm saying at all.
I'm saying you do know engineering automotive engineering is,
to me,
I'm a huge fan.
Pouring is watching and if it's not pouring on,
the Camry is watching how much money you're not spending on gas because you can
see how much gas mileage is you're getting on their little onboard computer,
you know?
No,
I understand what you're saying in that term,
but it's as far as like the kind of car it is,
it's a boring car.
It's got a sunroof.
That's exciting too.
And uh,
you know,
like I,
I can put on in lots of like awesome music.
Well,
I mean those are good things for sure.
What does that sound versus 12,800 wow.
That's not a bad looking car either.
12,000 bucks,
cheap car.
I honestly,
if you want my real opinion,
I think all the cars are pouring right now.
All cars are born.
These cars are boring.
Like I like me to call on the 70s yeah,
those were cool.
Yeah.
Oh for sure.
You bought the sixties really?
the 70s I started dealing with seventies in the 70s it became weird because the
gas crisis,
they started developing these really shitty shapes and really cheap cars and
competing with Japan and the 60s I saw like a seventies continental on the
street yesterday.
It was mind boggling.
Beautiful.
25 feet long,
short seventies Cadillacs to those.
I had a couple,
I had a seven 92 79 t bird,
uh,
with,
with uh,
uh,
tee tops that I drove.
I drove all across America and in 1994 and 95 and man,
I loved that car so much.
It was the most like awkward.
It never went above 65 miles an hour.
Like whatever.
It didn't matter.
Like this was 1994 and it was removable glass roof,
Bright Green for not,
I called it the emerald city.
It.
Tee tops kind of went away,
man.
He tops are awesome.
They were big with like smokey and the bandit.
Remember that.
But I agree with you though to a degree because like I went,
I met the people who worked for Toyota at the Environmental Media Association
awards that the Prius was a sponsor of.
And I said,
I'm not ever going to buy a Prius until you make one with a sunroof.
I was like exactly the same thing.
I was like,
why do you hate life wide?
Why can't I wear the sun?
Right.
Cause it's like you're right there is this,
this idea that they're boring.
But if you've ever gotten behind the wheel of a Tesla Dude,
oh I have.
Yeah,
there isn't real.
The engineering's phenomenal.
Yeah.
You hit the accelerator and your head just,
yeah,
I guess the bat and it's like a rush.
You can go zero to 60 in like two seconds.
Something crazy like that.
Well it's not quite that,
but it's close.
I mean it's a three something,
three say no.
And this is the new one.
That's all wheel drive.
I mean the,
the,
the engineering that they're coming out with with these things,
there's a new company that I was just communicating with them,
uh,
online,
a couple of days ago that has some fucking crazy new sports car,
uh,
Renoco where Novo Murray Motors,
it's kind of counterintuitive because it only
goes a hundred miles on a charge,
but what they're doing is they're essentially creating like an electric viper.
I mean,
it's just this fucking ridiculous.
His a hundred,
a thousand foot pounds of Torque,
which is unheard of.
So kind of like Philly,
what they're doing is just creating,
like I,
I'm,
I'm huge fan of engineering.
I'm a geek for technology.
So when I see someone just say,
okay,
what can,
what can be done now with everything we have,
what is the best version of this we can make,
you know?
Yeah.
It's not reasonable.
It's not affordable for almost anybody.
I can't afford one to half a million dollars.
One of these fucking things.
That's the car right there.
Crazy.
It's insane.
But it's good looking too.
Almost like a sixties.
Yeah,
it's beautiful.
Aston Martin or something like that.
It's beautiful,
beautiful car.
The shape is awesome,
the spearmint,
but a hundred miles.
I mean,
dude,
fuck
driving.
I drove.
I've driven in every single state.
The one contradiction here is that gasoline and movies are road movies.
Like
I am,
I love being out on the open road in a car.
I will disappear for months.
I mean,
like,
there's nothing more exciting to me now.
I mean,
I made gas and guessing at two in [inaudible] 92 Camry and 93 Camry and like
slept by the side of the road and just,
you know,
I mean,
New Mexico just pull off,
just go to sleep under the stars like Wyoming next to the hoback river.
Like on your way up to Yosemite.
You know,
these,
this is the most amazing thing about America.
I mean like America is those roads out in the west.
And I just,
I'm in love with it.
Like I hate flying with a passion.
I'm actually going to take the train back from here because I want to film it.
I want to figure out what it's like to take the train.
Um,
but you want to talk about infrastructure development,
why don't we have high speed trains to take us from La to New York and Elan Musk
ridiculous working on that.
Right.
And the the,
but,
but what I'm saying is that like,
I just,
you know,
I think it's an amazing thing and it's definitely has to be worked out because
and that's what's going to take the transition because you buy a new car right
now,
it's going to last you 10.
It's going to be on the road for 10 or 15 years.
There's another environmental impact that we're not thinking about when it comes
to planes.
The people that lived near airplanes there,
they're showing all these studies now,
the lung diseases and all sorts of health risks that people have to just live
near airports because the burning of these fossil fuels,
I can massive amounts,
just jet engines burning off untold millions of gallons.
Okay.
So fuels per year.
And you know,
the,
the airline industry is,
um,
would be equivalent to a medium size,
you know,
country in terms of admissions.
And I think you're meeting besides European country.
I'm don't quote,
well I just said it,
but you know,
it's,
it's a big sector of emissions and especially since you consider a lot of these
flights are going over Alaska and going over the Poles,
they're depositing their emissions there.
So you actually have a greater amount of CO2 in the up in the polar ice cap
where we actually need it to be colder because it's reflecting a lot of the,
uh,
of the Sun's light going back out into space because of the white ice sheets up
there.
So you want them to be,
um,
uh,
go cold.
Um,
but basically up in the,
in the polls you have more emissions because a lot of the flights are crossing
over the top there cause they're going from the,
you know,
I say see Europe,
United States to Asia.
Those are going to be polar routes isn't one of the big concerns with these
electric vehicles.
The actual material of the batteries themselves.
Like a lot of it is coming from story called conflict minerals.
And you know,
a lot of us coming from these places like the Congo or Afghanistan is a big
source of lithium for Lithium Ion batteries really?
Well.
It's one of the huge discoveries that they had a few years back that there's
more lithium in Afghanistan and like almost anywhere in the world.
Yeah.
It's trillions of dollars of lithium that they're going to pull out of the
ground to make batteries with.
And that's one of the reasons why they believe the United States had a vested
interest in staying in Afghanistan.
All sorts of,
but there's a huge on the gas pipeline.
Sure.
A natural gas pipeline,
which was what was being fought over during the Russian and Afghany the,
the whole mujahideen situation.
But when you look at these batteries that are in these cars,
they're really like kinda inefficient and issue.
It's a big issue or no question.
And that's why I'm saying like,
again,
the answer to these problems is trying to take some kind of collective
responsibility when we go through our regular daily life.
Um,
we don't,
you know,
I mean like people say,
oh,
I recycle.
And I think that's all fine.
That's all good.
That should be just like no brainer.
But what we're talking about is trying to make these types of decisions where we
know of the consequences and we have to be able to process them.
But we do know that one of the big things that is,
um,
from,
from the standpoint of all of these issues that you're bringing up,
there is no question that oil and gas is at the top of the list,
both in terms of climate change and global warming,
but also in terms of these localized pollution effects which are getting less
and less local,
right?
Everyone's downstream from something.
Um,
but you're absolutely 100% right.
Solar farm,
solar panel manufacturing.
When manufacturing extractive though all those industries don't get a pass just
because their renewable energy,
they have to be subject to very vigorous laws that control the damage that they
do as well.
Otherwise,
you're going to repeat the cycle with a new industry.
And in fact,
if you don't actively oppose oil and gas,
if you don't say we have to keep the oil in the ground.
Okay,
let's say you ban,
uh,
or you shut down all the coal fire power plant in the United States.
If we don't,
what we're going to do,
if we don't stop it is export the coal and we're exporting tons of coal right
now out of the United States where we're using,
we want
to export the gas even if we don't use the gas here.
So it's gotta be about keeping it in the ground.
Um,
there's another problem which is that if you create more energy,
all of a sudden people go,
oh,
there's energy,
it's great.
I can just use lots of energy.
So you end up building more of everything.
So you might end up in a situation where energy becomes cheaper and then people
use more of it.
And we haven't actually made any progress.
So it is a question of making those kinds of limitations on keeping the oil or
coal and gas in the ground and live,
not just multiplying it so that you end up using more.
And there's plenty of examples of countries that don't have any regulation on
environments like look at what the fuck is going on in China.
When you see these cities that are just toxic cities.
There's cities in China where they have just gray skies from pollution and
people wearing masks.
Like was it,
and B we're going to be on,
I'm going to go out there at some point in the next six months I think,
but in,
I haven't been there yet,
but I cause that all coal a coal,
um,
they're starting to try to frack in China,
but they don't have a lot of water.
Um,
you know,
China,
but China just made this enormous commitment,
right?
Like I said,
800 to a thousand gigawatts of renewable energy.
Um,
but yeah,
in Beijing,
it so bad that they broadcast,
I think on televisions,
the sunset in certain places they broadcast the sunset cause you can't see it.
You can't say,
I want to see that.
I want to take it.
Well,
there's the,
I mean,
I just think that there's examples,
like we get to see this spectrum of,
of,
you know,
places where it's like completely sustainable and beautiful and natural.
I mean,
you can go to the Colorado Rockies and see how beautiful and clean fresh the
areas and they didn't go to Beijing and you could say,
oh well people are capable of this too.
You know,
you can go to a place like boulder that doesn't let anybody build in the
mountains.
Like they have a very strict
go 10 miles away in weld county,
which is frack to hell too.
You know,
so you have the first world in the third world and the third world in the first
world.
That's just the way it is.
And what defines what defines,
um,
the poverty of those locations is,
I think the health of their environment.
It's not,
the scary thing too is that people are doing things that can they,
the,
the thing that freaks me out about fracking and the feeling like when I see the
pros and the cons and I see the arguments for and against,
the one thing that seems to be undeniable is that you can't clean it up.
It's like it gets to the per,
is it gets to a certain point where,
you know,
we don't want to be in a place where,
um,
the entire plants on life support.
And what I mean by that is you have to purify and treat every single drop of
water that you found.
You don't want to get there.
No,
we're not that far from there though.
Um,
but the truth is that,
yeah,
you,
you're making a good point that a lot of these,
it's the,
I say at the end of gasoline to environmental victories are always temporary,
but the loss is always seemed to be permanent.
You can't restore,
you know,
some of these incredibly by,
um,
you know,
biologically diverse areas by replanting with,
something else that there's,
there's a bottom line to what nature has made that needs to at this point
actually have rights and be precise,
be preserved.
Um,
you know,
and,
uh,
that's,
that's a big part of all of this.
But I,
I do I got to say that in the midst of all of this incredibly negative,
difficult information,
I'm very positive about it.
I'm very,
um,
I have,
I,
I'm not gonna say I'm optimistic because I don't really know,
you know,
but I do feel a real positive charge from being involved.
And that's the thing,
like,
you feel better about being involved with this,
right?
When it first came to my backyard,
I have to,
I spent three weeks sleepless nights.
Could not sleep,
could not,
it was terrified and never felt more alone.
You know,
th thinking like,
oh my God,
you know,
cause when you live in a beautiful area like that,
this environmentally,
um,
uh,
pristine,
you're always kind of waiting for the ax to fall.
Know whether it's going to be like a mega casino or a Walmart or a oil and gas
was too nice.
Someone's going to fuck it up.
You know,
cause yeah.
Cause unlike a lot of other places,
um,
but you know,
I never felt more alone.
I mean nowadays,
you know,
like I mentioned,
if you're involved in this,
you can go anywhere and have friends.
It's,
it's a wonderful feeling to know that you're connected on that level.
I mean,
I've toured in addition to putting these films on Hbo,
which is a massive exposure,
a couple of million people each time we do that with the films.
Um,
we've toured grassroots too.
I have toured to 300 cities around the world just to meet people and talk to
them and give them answers.
And that's an incredible,
not answers but answer questions,
have a discussion.
That's an incredible experience.
Um,
being in life.
Yeah.
I think it's cool that people are waking up and realizing that we're involved in
this society that really hasn't been thought out that well in terms of a
sustainability or the impact of the future.
Like,
I remember Fukushima when that happened.
It was a huge wake up call for a lot of folks and they realize you can't shut
off these plants when they go offline like that.
When,
when when the power gets disrupted and there's no ability to cool the rods,
like everyone's fucked.
Like that area is fucked eternally.
I mean it will be fucked a hundred thousand years from now.
It will be fucked for longer than there've been people.
And then this is something that we just did.
I'm not a,
I'm not an expert on that for sure.
Well the half life worry me,
it's like a hundred thousand years.
How many,
how long has it been people in this form?
Has it been in pointing out 200 years.
A lot of the fracking chemicals don't biodegrade.
So you're talking about putting things into the earth.
We need to shoot it into the space.
That's what we need to do.
The aliens come back and kick our ass assholes litter in.
Did
you guys do this?
Launch this fucking shit in space
and then we'll find out that the environmental cost of using the jets to
launching the space accelerating global warming.
It's,
well,
I mean I,
yeah,
I mean the the,
the truth of the matter is though that these problems have answers and the and
the,
the problems boil down to being political problems,
social problems.
As much as they end up paying chemics chemistry problems and contamination
problems,
they are really about how skewed our system is right now and who's got the
leavers of control of the end and what I,
what I'm seeing start to happen,
which is really remarkable is people starting to win.
Well that's cool.
Information information becomes undeniable in this day and age.
This is this too much of it.
It's just like it's too easy to just do research and see the studies.
It's too easy to look at the environmental impact that you could literally see
where your own eyes and also to see where the influence is to see the system
that's in place.
Is this system in place because it's the best way to do it or is a system in
place because people are already hugely influential and extracting massive
amounts of money and then spreading that massive amounts of money to our quote
unquote representatives through lobbyists and what have you.
And then that's the hold up.
Is that the hold up?
I mean it seems like that's the whole whole,
well that was the question of gas and parking now,
which is that we saw this huge movement on fracking.
Um,
and then we saw and we had the most,
uh,
you know,
in a way liberal progressive president we've had in a long,
long time.
Why wasn't there more action on this?
Why didn't we see change when all of a sudden,
and that was the question.
So gasoline to became this investigation into the government,
um,
and it wasn't about fracking contaminants in the water and fracking pollutants
in the air.
It was about these fracking dollars that were contaminating the political
system.
Um,
and that was really the investigation.
How does that happen?
And what we found was really startling.
And it's,
we're DEF,
definitely.
I would say no,
it's on my,
my own film,
but definitely worth watching that because this is all about a trilogy for me.
You know,
looking at first my kind of consciousness,
opening up and understanding what was happening with fracking in the first movie
about environmental issues.
The second movie really about being gay,
about government and about how government was treating the crisis and this last
film,
which is not a gas land film.
The last film of this sort of trilogy and my mind is about climate and it's
about the whole ball of wax.
It's about how are we going to deal with this climate crisis from the standpoint
of,
um,
all of these systems in place.
It seems like people are more aware of how fucked up our process is now than
have ever been before.
I think people kind of looked at democratic process when I was a kid.
My parents were,
you know,
uh,
my age.
They,
they,
they didn't really have this awareness of the whole system that was in place.
But what can that do sometimes that
can make you cynical and detached and apathetic.
Um,
the antidote to that is to get involved and then it makes you,
um,
it leads you down a pathway,
which is more connected and,
and I think ultimately more fulfilling.
Well,
there's always going to be,
you know,
whenever there's a problem,
any kind of a problem,
there's going to be people that respond in different ways.
Like some people respond to being overweight by saying,
fuck,
and I'm fat.
I'm just going to keep eating cheeseburgers.
And some people look at themselves and go,
you know what?
I just need to start doing something about this vehicle and this meat wagon.
Then I'm traveling around this world and,
and cleaning it up.
And now it's a,
it's that choice.
It's like there's a lot of factors involved in national is the one that is less
depressing when you're actually active.
And that's the point,
right?
Yeah.
Aye.
I'll quote mark Ruffalo again and saying,
if you're depressed,
you're not doing enough.
Um,
like if you,
or something like that.
I think that's true though,
that if you're feeling afraid and isolated and um,
and depressed and sad about these things,
the antidote isn't Prozac.
Um,
or more therapy.
Although,
you know,
those things might help you.
The antidote is to get involved and to work with your fellow man and woman and
your neighbors and your community to do something about this because we,
you know,
we can't,
um,
I mean this,
this is from self experience.
I mean like I get exhausted and I get downtrodden,
I get upset,
I get worried and I get freaked out.
And then the antidote is always to go back out and talk to people,
work with them,
and then you feel like this charge,
now I'm here.
Um,
and yeah,
information helps.
Um,
and you know,
we have these,
I mean it was at this community in the Amazon of of of a thousand people,
you know,
four and a half hours down river from the nearest population center,
which wasn't a big population center.
Um,
and they have solar powered Internet and uh,
that's true.
Hut.
Well yeah,
watch porn.
They weren't doing that.
They weren't,
there aren't there are,
trust me when you're not there.
Really interesting.
I didn't think about that.
Of course they are.
There's no way around it.
Human beings like watching naked human beings.
There's just no way around that.
The areas that you went to where the,
uh,
the crisis of um,
the oil spills and the pipelines braking,
is there any effort to clean that up?
I went with Amazon Watch.
Um,
they were our kind of guides.
There's a,
uh,
amazing local affiliated organization called Alejan Sakana.
Um,
we were guided by,
uh,
these folks who are environmental monitors that are sort of self,
um,
uh,
there,
there's a system of indigenous environmental monitors that go out into the
jungle and find these things and report
on them.
Um,
but I would say right now
what we're going to try,
and I haven't said any of this up yet,
but when I'm going to try to do with the release of the new film,
since there are actually a lot of organizations that kind of guide us through
the process.
There's occupy sandy,
when we're looking at Hurricane Sandy,
there's Amazon Washington,
Allianz Arcada and these incredible environmental monitors and these indigenous
parts of uh,
of,
of Peru and Ecuador.
There's a foundation called empowered by light,
which helps distribute solar panels in Zambia.
So when the film actually comes out,
we're going to connect our audience to a lot of those organizations that are
doing that work to be a kind of funnel in the same way that we tried to be a
funnel for the fracking movement.
So if you went to Gaston and the movie.com and you put in your zip code,
you could find the fracking organizations in your,
in your local area or the national organizations working on fracking.
I think for the same,
in the same way,
we're going to try to connect people through the film to these organizations.
But right now I haven't done enough of that work to kind of set up the
mechanism.
But when we do release this new film,
which is currently entitled,
um,
there at the website,
you'll definitely have links to Amazon wash and only answer Connor and empowered
by light.
And occupy sandy and some of the,
uh,
northern Colorado rebuilders who rebuilt each other's homes in the midst of the
high park fire,
the biggest fire.
Um,
in recent times,
um,
you know,
where there is a solution,
we're going to try to connect our audience.
Right?
Have you been a,
uh,
able to,
or invited to debate any of your detractors on any of these subjects?
Because you're very informed.
You,
you have all the statistics you pull,
obviously this has been a huge part of your life for many years now.
I've done it on TV as much times.
I mean,
I don't want to suck,
man.
You get these three minute fucking abused,
two heads on two different frames and one,
you know,
Fox News person who's buried.
I have
no credibility.
I won't debate people who have no credibility.
So if you have some kind of charlatan who's like,
you know,
um,
like trying to just make a name for himself,
uh,
to do this,
I won't even do the one that tried to get,
I want it to try to get in the room with t Boone Pickens,
who is that?
He's connatural star from the 60s,
t Boone Pickens,
t bone Burnett,
I think.
But t Boone Pickens is a guy who was promoting natural gas,
who was in oil baron.
Um,
and he refused to talk to me in written debate.
How weird.
Um,
yeah,
totally flat teeth.
And in fact t Boone
Pickens mouth.
Yeah.
They flat out refused.
Um,
and,
uh,
I've tried,
I want it to get people who are actually representative of the oil industry to
talk to me about that,
or,
you know,
uh,
those,
government officials,
I would do that.
Um,
but what the oil and gas industry has done is create these,
um,
you know,
PR firms.
There's one called energy in depth,
which is just a fracking,
I mean,
it was created by the super majors.
It was created by Shell and BP with,
uh,
and Chesapeake with money,
um,
for their,
uh,
and I,
I,
you know,
I've,
I've done a few,
um,
against them.
Early on,
they invited me to Tulsa,
Oklahoma,
where they ganged up on me and I debated them.
And,
um,
that would,
that's online.
There's a great one.
When I was in Frostburg,
Maryland,
we're an oil and gas engineer.
Uh,
we did a debate and another one in Arkansas.
They're,
they're not,
they don't get a lot of attention.
Um,
but they're fun though.
They're fun to kind of destroy them.
What are their,
what are their arguments?
What do they sell?
Their arguments are that the,
there are no environmental impacts that you can't prove them.
I mean,
they're,
they say these things that are just utterly 100% false.
And then you can say,
well,
the,
here's this study and here's that study and here's one by scientists and here's
one by your own industry.
Um,
so they lose every time.
That's a debate.
But why do they have them then if they do,
they know they're going to where they just so confident that they think they're
just going to be able to smooth talk their way through the whole thing.
You'd have to ask them Fox News at all.
Well,
the ones on TV work very much like the way you just said.
I mean,
unfortunately in these types of scenarios,
you know,
it kind of gets a little egg heady and boring to explain
science,
but that's the only way to really truly debate.
But it's harder.
It's hard to do that in soundbite,
those fucking shows,
man,
when they have to be like,
you know,
someone said,
all right,
we're going to talk to Josh Fox from the movie Gasland and next to him is Satan
and
Satan is a money fucking coming out of his collar and money is,
he just stuffed his jacket stuffed with money.
And I mean it's,
it's so hard to fucking you dealing with these three minute chunks and it's
like,
who talks over people?
You do it over and over again.
And that's been my experience.
You know,
Peter Schiff is economics guy,
really,
really interesting guy.
And He's,
um,
uh,
one of the few guys that he's a very controversial and he's always on these,
occupy Wall Street things and he doesn't believe in the market the way it's set
up right now.
And he's,
he's firmly,
firmly believes that they should have allowed the banks to collapse because they
were,
they sucked and they weren't functioning properly.
And in a free market you allow things to fail and then you rebuild and would
have been better for everybody and that this bailout was very detrimental to our
process.
Anyway,
I had him on the podcast and it's so interesting watching him talk because
brilliant guy,
but he's used to talking like really fast cause you have like seven minutes to
bang this out.
I'm like,
dude,
we got ours and we were cool so he could see like an hour in.
Oh he like he settles back,
we start drinking and we brought in some whiskey,
settled.
He be,
it's that,
that style that you become accustomed to when you do those debates of just
rapid,
oh sure.
One
window on the left and one window of the right and you got seven minutes,
seven minutes and everyone's trying to make their point.
And it's a skill that you have to develop but you'd look and there's no way to
learn it unless you keep doing it.
Got to go to,
so luck,
luckily,
you know,
um,
I've been able to learn that,
you know,
it's been Dick,
look,
if,
if you ask me in 2010 would I still be doing this in 2014?
There was no way I would say,
yeah.
I mean like,
I mean,
I don't know.
Let's try it in 2008,
that's when he started to start crossing something in 2008.
But,
you know,
I mean,
I'm a theater director and if at a playwright and a film maker,
I'm looking at your fingernails.
You obviously play guitar,
Banjo,
Banjo.
But like the,
the thing is that,
that,
um,
you know,
I'm used to moving from one project to the next,
to the next to the next.
It's been an incredible sustained effort to work on this.
But what's amazing about it is that it's constantly rewarding and fulfilling to
do it.
And that when you enter into this,
um,
moment of thinking about all these issues that we've been talking about,
I think it really changes your brain and you can see,
you know,
there might be one main river of the work that you're doing,
but there's thousands of tributaries that are going into that and they're
fascinating and there's thousands of other subjects that you could use to branch
off of this that are entered,
you know,
enough to really keep you occupied.
And I love the act of interviewing people for a documentary.
I love the act of,
of meeting people that way.
Um,
there's something about it which I think is really amazing that you can meet on
another level that way.
Cause you have your agenda shines through to people and if you really care about
what you're doing,
they recognize that you care.
And all of a sudden it's not an interview anymore.
It's a friendship.
And Al Maysles,
the great document documentary filmmaker who,
um,
who was in his eighties who made salesman and grey gardens and,
and gimme shelter,
he said to me,
the whole process is a friendship.
You get to know,
and then everybody gets to know.
So some of my best friends in the world at this point of the people who started
off as subjects of my films,
who we went to spend some time with them at their place in Wyoming or at their
place in Zambia or at their place in,
um,
Pennsylvania or somewhere.
And,
and you become friends with them.
Um,
you know,
and you,
and you know,
I get Christmas cards from them,
like you have to catch up with them.
And you know,
like John Fenton who's in the gas in both gas and one and two who was in
pavilion,
Wyoming,
his case was the shot heard around the world where they,
where EPA finally came in and said,
Yup,
fracking fluids have contaminated the water here.
And it's because of fracking.
Um,
you know,
he's one of my best friends on the planet right now.
And I just,
you know,
like I,
I don't know what my life would be like if I didn't have these people's
friendship and their comradery and,
you know,
it's just like,
what life is now.
So it's um,
yeah.
And,
and you know,
we started to just talk this question was about soundbites.
I think that's just a skill that you have to try to figure out.
Um,
you know,
luckily,
uh,
you know,
I feel comfortable doing that.
Um,
I think a lot of the time it's very taxing them.
Do you stay in touch with some of those folks that were having some pretty
profound health consequences to fracking?
Like that woman who was a really sick because of the filters that they were
using to filter out their water,
wasn't filtering out those specific toxins.
John [inaudible] has lost all of his hair.
He's lost his eyebrows.
Whoa.
He has constant ringing in his ears.
Um,
well he,
we,
he went up,
he had two different forms of alopecia that,
one of which can be caused by chemical exposure.
Although the research on that is very,
um,
it gets better when he leaves town.
So raises eyebrows back when he leaves town starting,
I'm going to fucking move.
Really Weird.
Well,
that's a big question,
right?
A lot of these people have moved or were forced to move and they're thinking
about it the way,
you know,
way he deals with it.
He tries to leave from time to time.
But you know,
when you have built your own home by hand and you're on your wife's parents to
several generations farm in Wyoming,
it's not always that easy to leave.
Now do these guys,
even how you're living into these spots that are fucked up,
some cases,
sometimes they have a percentage of the mineral rights,
sometimes they don't.
Um,
you know,
uh,
Calvin Tillman for example,
the mayor of dish,
Texas who's also a friend,
good friend.
Um,
he did leave,
he left the,
the mayor moves out of his own town and got,
and you know,
that's what I say in the film.
You know,
it's like when,
when things are bad,
you know,
things are bad when the mayor moves out of town and he left and he started to
raise his kids in the next town over where they didn't have shale.
And what was his issue environment and what was,
is a health issue.
Um,
well his,
he was worried about his kids getting nose bleeds.
He was worried about getting those places.
They were getting nose bleeds in the night.
There were,
the asthma was getting worse.
They had,
um,
uh,
breathing issues and he was having a new,
daughter on the way.
They were planning another child.
I have two sons that,
and you know,
um,
his wife says,
you know,
it look,
I mean we,
they did monitoring of the health of the whole town and they found elevated
levels of a whole host of illnesses.
Um,
and do they do,
it starts with nosebleeds and it starts to become a respiratory problems,
but then you don't know like what,
what are they going to be?
The longterm effects of this.
But they've had exposure that they mapped out from,
from um,
ambient benzene in the air.
Um,
uh,
dimethyl sulfides,
other,
I'm trying to remember the play,
but if you're looking gasoline too,
you can see the maps that they did have longterm and short term,
uh,
exposures.
Uh,
and the,
those exposures can cause health effects in the whole town of dish,
Texas.
Um,
and these are directly attributed to these?
Oh yeah.
I was like,
well,
they have pipelines and they have oil and gas sites and they have compressor
stations.
So how far away do you have to get away before you don't experience the effects
of those chemicals?
That's what they did.
Some of that mapping,
this whole town of dish,
um,
had those effects of their fathers.
Yeah.
Well in a lot of people have moved.
Um,
and a lot of people have been,
uh,
that he goes down the street and one point in gas and two and says,
you know,
look,
I think it's 40% of these people are in a lawsuit trying to move because what
happens when you buy a house,
right?
You put all of your present and future assets into that house.
So if oil and gas comes in and destroys the area,
you've lost so much of that asset and the houses are worth a fraction of what
they used to be.
I mean,
um,
so your only choice at that point is to have a lawsuit to get out.
Now when you have a lawsuit,
um,
nine times out of 10 included in that settlement with the oil and gas.
Let's see,
when you get to the best case scenario,
you get a settlement for a couple of hundred thousand dollars.
Included in that settlement is a nondisclosure agreement,
which means you can never talk about what happened to you.
Um,
and nobody else can find it out,
uh,
in,
in a famous case in Pittsburgh or outside of Pittsburgh.
Um,
the how,
which family who are featured in gas name part two,
who ended up signing a nondisclosure agreement.
Um,
they got something like $700,000 to move to leave their homes.
and they did move.
But what was discovered when Pittsburgh Post Gazette pressed to get information
from that nondisclosure agreement because they argued that it was a matter of
public health.
They found out that the oil and gas industry had actually gagged.
They're eight and 10 year old children and PR,
Pr,
the gag.
The kids,
they said the kids couldn't talk about oil and gas or fracking or what had
happened to them.
And when the world you could do that.
How's an eight year old kid consent?
This is what my question was.
So this was featured on the Colbert report.
Um,
uh,
Stephen Colbert brought this up,
um,
and you know,
like lampooned and everything and I had an interview,
well and we'll go down that road but,
but another family that I know very well and it won't,
I can't say which one.
Um,
who had signed a nondisclosure agreement who had left their multigenerational
property in a state,
which people are very attached to their land and they had to end up leaving that
person.
A representative that family said to me,
hypothetically,
you get my meaning.
If I was in oil and gas company,
I might argue that unborn generations of future children would not be able to
speak about that and force you to negotiate from there.
You see what I'm saying?
So that he was indicating that the oil and gas company in question in this
particular case had tried to gag their unborn children
and that forced them to negotiate back from there.
How is that possible?
I just don't understand how it can be legally binding because the first
amendment,
um,
you know,
right free.
If the government tried to do it would be illegal,
right?
That pertains to the government.
Private corporations and private individuals can make the deals to gag each
other all they want.
It's not the government doing that.
The government can't tell you.
You can never speak about this.
That's against the first amendment,
but
it's not,
it doesn't count to.
But you know,
there's one thing that you can get around these nondisclosure agreements,
which is a congressional subpoena.
Um,
so,
um,
when Henry Waxman was doing an inquiry into fracking,
when the Democrats in the house had a subpoena power when they were in the
majority in 2010,
um,
they,
the Waksman Commission on fracking asked me,
can you connect us with people who aren't,
have nondisclosure agreements?
And we did.
We gave them,
we gave them names and they were able to testify.
And it's something that I've asked of several senators currently cause I mean,
well,
when the Democrats were in the majority,
I asked Senator Gillibrand is office,
can you please create a subpoena?
Um,
so that some of these people can come in and testify.
I've asked this over and over and over again of officials on the hill,
please,
let's have public hearings with the public,
not with oil and gas,
talking heads with people.
Let's have people testify in Congress or what's happening to them was oil and
gas contamination.
Why not do that?
I just can't imagine a world where it makes sense that you could put a gag order
on an eight year old.
That's this world.
Well,
especially when it comes to the surrogate.
You don't have to advance.
Imagine that at all.
Something like gas and oil.
I mean,
that just seems so criminal.
That just seems,
how could you sign that away?
I've little Timmy,
10 years from now,
it's kind of mafioso weird kind of godfather came the thing,
right?
It's creepy.
It's creepy that that's,
or North Korea where you've got multiple generations in jail.
These are multiple generations that can't speak about what you wrote on their
property
or actually what you didn't agree to admit to doing,
but you paid them to leave and shut up.
That's amazing because most of those courts that was don't have any admission of
wrongdoing and how many people are actually winning in court for me,
did they settle with these folks just to get them to shut out cord is,
um,
you know,
it was a,
it was Ron Paul who was running for president right in 2010,
2008,
I think,
who was arguing that we should do it with the EPA because all of these
individual contamination cases can be handled in the courts.
Let me tell you,
you don't want to take the oil and gas industry on in court,
you know,
um,
I mean,
they have you,
they will put motions and thousands of dollars and thousands of lawyers and you
don't want to try to take these guys on in,
in,
in court by yourself.
I mean,
I asked,
um,
there's a case in gas and then part two,
in Texas where the EPA was enforcing an,
uh,
an,
an imminent and substantial endangerment order,
uh,
the Lipski family who were the ones who can light their water hose on fire,
um,
out of the backyard out of there,
a water wall.
Um,
because the top of the,
of headspace of the water wall venting off so much gas that they can just,
the hose that they attach to the top of the border wall just lights every single
time and now they have this pipe that they can light off the top.
Um,
that EPA got involved there.
And then at a certain point after Obama's 2012 speech on touting the virtues of
the natural gas,
all these EPA investigations shut down.
They shut down in Pennsylvania and Texas and Wyoming.
Um,
and uh,
this was extremely suspicious to me.
Right.
And this is what we report on it and guessing that part too.
Um,
you know,
I asked the EPA and the one of the EPA officials off the record said to me,
well,
we were worried that the gas company in question was going to outspend the
government on legal fees.
So we simply couldn't afford as the government to keep her prosecuting this
case.
That's so crazy.
So I,
I went to NRDC,
I went to a number of,
uh,
Sierra club and went to try to get advocacy to say,
can you please take this case on?
These people are left in the lurch with nothing.
And they said,
well,
you know,
what makes you think we can take it on if they were going to outspend the
government,
they're going to outspend us.
I mean,
like this one,
these are the questions,
right?
Because you can just take motion after motion and tie things up in court and do
this for decades.
The amount of money that they have,
it's just so scary.
It's like government money.
It's like they be more than that.
I mean,
I mean like they are a government,
like a,
an entire country.
I mean,
it's like that kind of money.
So it's so,
it's just so hard to believe that things have gone solo ride,
that you have this huge,
huge industry that is poisoning people and then paying them to shut the fuck
that I can sit here and I could sit here and tell you that all of New York state
just did the impossible but you must be so happy about that because I feel like
a huge victory.
Yeah,
of course.
I was actually coming out of five days in the Amazon jungle having investigated
oil spills on foot and in boats and incredibly arduous out of contact and we
were coming out on the boat and we were passing by a cell tower and my phone
blows up as they're,
as they're making the announcement and made it back to civilization in time to
go on Chris Hayes that night and do it live Skype from the,
from the Amazon.
It was,
did you film the texts coming in the next day?
Cause I was like too,
like I filmed the texts the next day.
I think there are some reactions shots.
And because I was actually on the front,
I was on the bow of the boat,
like hanging out,
like getting a Tan,
like listening to my tunes.
Wow.
And I was like just hanging out and not doing much and all of a sudden like my
phone,
which I was playing music on,
um,
in my headphones just starts to go beep.
And I was like,
well that's weird.
And like I guess my is working again.
You know,
cause we were like halfway out on the Marin you own river cause it could hear
the behind it,
pick it up and then I was like,
no way.
You do.
You anticipate that this is going to be like this is just the start.
It's gonna start trickling down other states or moving things trickle down.
It'll be a domino if we make it try me on.
It's a bad word.
It certainly helps.
But I want to ask,
um,
you know,
all those people who made New York possible to get involved in the fight in PA
and get involved in the fight in California.
I mean,
I think we have to be strategic about it.
I think from a national organizing stand point in New York was always strategic.
The idea that,
um,
New York mattered enormously.
Not just because New York is beautiful and matters and we don't get fracked up,
but also because if we can get that win,
then there's a huge win for science.
There's a win for reason.
There's a win for grassroots,
but now without question,
that movement has to double down,
be more vigorous in Pennsylvania and Ohio and Maryland and Colorado and
California now too.
I think that there are certain places that we should focus on because we have a
chance,
um,
you know,
where we actually have viable energy.
Absolutely.
Um,
there's a new governor in Pennsylvania,
his name is governor Wolf.
Um,
he is the ferry first governor of Pennsylvania ever to be elected.
when there was an incumbent that was running and other VA has never thrown out
of governor before.
Real.
Yeah.
Um,
so,
and this man is a Democrat and he has now the huge weight and moral
responsibility of all the havoc that the fracking industry is,
is wreaking in Pennsylvania and does any part of the platform that he ran on.
He was very wishy washy about it.
He's already got a contradiction in his policy.
He's pro fracking,
but he's against fracking in the Delaware River basin.
Now that's unequal protection under the law in my book.
Right.
So why should people in the river base and have extra protection whereas other
people in the rest of Pennsylvania don't.
That's a big problem.
That's why New York is all hundred percent frack free because if they were going
to ban it in the New York City watershed and not ban it like in,
you know,
Arthur or something New York,
um,
or Alfred New York,
uh,
you know,
then there was a problem.
You have a mistake.
Cause if you don't ban it and out,
if an Alfred and you've been in New York City watershed,
well the oil and gas industry can sue you and say,
look,
oh,
we should be able to open up and drove to New York City watershed.
So they kind of had to do,
you know,
one law for everybody.
Governor Wolf has already kind of,
in principle,
I'm broken that,
uh,
that ideal,
right to say,
all right,
well,
we're not going to have any change in the river basin,
which means fracking would be no good for the Delaware River Basin,
but we're going to allow it in the sauce,
my hand or river basin or in the Allegheny river basin.
That's a huge problem.
So he's got compromised and he's not even in office yet.
He's governor elect.
But on January 20th in Harrisburg,
I will be there with an incredible fracking activists,
Pennsylvania against fracking and clean water action and a whole host of folks
to protest that and start to talk about how this governor has to pay attention
in the same way that governor Cuomo had to pay attention.
Harrisburg is all that's rush limbo country.
Um,
Harrisburg is the is,
you know,
I mean I friends and family used to live there.
Really?
Yeah.
They're like,
it's so right wing.
That's one of the reasons why they moved.
They were like,
this is crazy.
You Ed Rendell,
governor of PA,
former governor of PA who opened the doors for the fracking industry famously
calls it Pennsyltucky PA is Pittsburgh and Philadelphia in Kentucky.
In between.
I don't know if I believe that.
I mean,
I,
it doesn't matter to me.
Like I said,
like there's the first world in the third world,
but then there's the blue areas and the red states and the red areas and the
blue states and where I played doesn't really matter.
Um,
you know,
we play in red areas in blue states and,
and blueberries and rest days just as much as anywhere in the blue is the blue
and the reddest of the red.
We've got a phenomenon happening in the America,
which is green tea.
You know,
you gotta talk about fracking from a progressive stand point.
You're going to talk about all the things that we just talked about,
environmental issues,
social inequality,
inequality,
etc. If you're talking about it from a,
um,
a land rights perspective,
private property rights is one of the bulwarks of conservative philosophy.
You don't have any private property rights at the fracking area.
So you've got people who,
um,
if I had the card in my pocket,
I pulled it out and showed you,
but my,
my wallet,
I went into the Amazon.
Um,
and it disintegrated.
It was,
uh,
it's called,
um,
Marcellus patriots for land rights.
It's got the don't tread on me snake with an oil rig going right through it.
These are conservative guys who go to sea pack every year who are adamantly
anti-fracking.
Um,
so you have this strange bedfellows thing happening where you've got
anti-fracking activists in the middle of rural Pennsylvania who vote
conservative or who have conservative values all of a sudden realizing that,
um,
they're on the same side as environmentalist from New York.
So that's an interesting conversation to be a part of.
Well,
it's just survival.
It's just a matter of recognizing that you can't just keep fucking polluting
everywhere.
That's not conservative or liberal,
but conservative,
conservative ideologies and mindsets.
They get trapped.
People get trapped in this one sort of team mentality and that team is like
always support big business or we support industry.
All we support the creation of jobs.
Those things are wrapped around occasional unfortunate things that happened to
the environment and Poo Poo,
not a big deal.
The real big deal was that we created all these different jobs and all these
liberals want to save the spotted owl and those fucks on an understand about
logging and you know those,
those kinds of mindsets.
And a lot of times what's really crazy?
Well,
it's about this spotted person,
this point,
right?
Well,
it's also the weird thing about those mindsets.
It's a lot of those people are poor.
A lot of those conservative folks are poor and it doesn't benefit them at all.
But they've locked themselves into this sort of a very rigid,
not a revelation to say that very smartly conservative element that's aligned
with the 1% and big business found social issues,
that we're going to be resonant among people who are in rural areas who are
poor,
right.
Um,
and,
and use those as wedge as to,
to do,
to make people vote against their own economic and enact wells to gay marriage
somehow,
or another fracking to gay marriage.
But what's really exciting and interesting is like I've had,
um,
at our production space in Brooklyn when,
when there were things to do in New York,
you know,
we had,
um,
uh,
one of the guys who was running,
um,
New Yorkers against fracking who is HIV positive gay man who was living in the
house hosting conservative c pack.
You know,
dudes from central PA living under the same roof,
hanging out,
starting to talk about these things.
And that was amazing.
And I wish I had taped that conversation,
you know,
between the guy with the rainbow flag and the guy with like conservative values
from Ronald Reagan.
Yeah.
Like,
and it was remarkable to see the change happen,
um,
uh,
change where these people acknowledged each other and,
and,
uh,
the openness,
um,
that it created.
And I,
so I think there's hope there.
I mean that's one of the things I just couldn't believe watching this
conversation between these two guys,
have you experienced much personal backlash from this?
I mean,
if people gone after you,
is there been like some weird moments where all personal,
it's so weird,
like you could look at a smear campaign from outside and go,
oh,
that shouldn't affect you at all.
That's a total,
you know,
but it does get you,
and especially when,
you know,
when you get really get into it,
and they,
they ran ads,
you know,
in Ohio of me smoking cigarettes,
like at a La,
I made the movie premiere in 2008,
you know,
I used to smoke,
I quit smoking,
you know,
and they would do this to run personally and say,
oh look,
look at this guy.
He's a total hypocrite and everything.
Cause you were smoking.
What,
how does that make you hypocrite?
Well,
cause I'm talking to him about carcinogens in the water supply and all of a
sudden,
you know,
I was smoking and this was,
this is a picture from 2008 a long time ago.
Um,
well I think I smoked an hour ago.
No,
not an hour ago.
Um,
you know,
you,
you quit for 10 years,
but it would have definitely been off cigarettes for rail antenna.
So a along the way,
did you realize like,
Hey,
I can't keep talking about environmental impacts and health impacts when I'm
poisoning myself?
Sure.
So part of the reason why I quit,
um,
I think so.
I mean,
I think you just quit when you feel like you have to grit and that's also had a
couple of relatives get cancer,
not lung cancer,
but you know,
it did wakes you up.
Um,
I dunno.
I mean,
I don't,
I've never,
I've not really ever talked about this in,
in,
in any kind of public forum.
Um,
I mean,
when you're in the theater and you're a filmmaker and you know,
like,
do you smoke?
I mean,
people smoke.
Um,
I actually started smoking when I was in a play out of the glass menagerie when
I was 17.
Um,
I was playing Tom and the glass menagerie and that role calls for you to smoke
five cigarettes during the performance.
Um,
so that started me,
but like,
um,
you know,
uh,
I think that there was a,
I think that there is,
um,
a problem when we stop being human beings and start being like pods of
information that can't have contradictions.
Right.
The idea that,
but at the same time,
like it's not something I wanted.
Like they will use every piece of information they have against you if the Ken
of course.
Right.
So you don't want to give any fodder for that.
Um,
you know,
did I quit smoking because I thought it would be pressure?
No,
I quit because I felt like I wanted to quit.
You know what I mean?
I felt like I was done with that and it was a problem.
Um,
but do I think that,
you know,
we're not all,
uh,
I mean you can't be a saint.
Um,
you know,
but at the same time,
like I think that what the,
that's maybe a good example of kind of downward pressure.
Like you've probably,
you may have noticed that during this two hour,
whatever interview you've cursed,
like 25 times.
And I haven't at all.
I don't notice that.
Well,
I haven't at all and no,
no,
I won't because,
because I just think that to a certain degree,
it's,
it's not respectful to some of the people who are in my audience.
We have one,
we have one curse in gas land and it's worth it and one in gasoline to,
well,
what,
these are the kinds of things that,
whether or not you want to record,
you want to recognize it,
they will either use it against you or you have to realize like what's
underneath it.
All right.
Um,
do I want to,
I don't want to do that right now in this role as a person who is working on
these issues because they will get in the way and it's easy enough to not do
that.
And then to examine the reasons why you would or wouldn't,
you know,
um,
it's one of those things that I think,
uh,
a lot of people really get into that it's hard.
It's a burden to to put yourself out in public and be exposed in the way that
you are,
but especially in individual,
individual with limited financial resources going up against an empire.
I mean,
that's what you're doing.
You're going up against the oil empire.
Yeah.
You were a significant bump in the road.
I,
I think it's,
um,
I,
the more I like to think of it more as that these films were a vehicle for
people to start to understand what was happening to each other,
right?
That's why gas land is in 12 states because it's a comparative study in it.
I wanted to show people in Pennsylvania,
look,
this is what's happening in Wyoming.
This is what's happening in Arkansas.
This is what's happening in Texas.
And these are people from a broad spectrum of political opinions.
So they're not all progressive lefty type folks.
They're not all conservatives either.
I actually didn't ask most of the people where their politics were,
but the idea that there's,
um,
this was connective tissue and I,
I want,
I have to go out and represent that,
you know,
as well as the fact that I,
I have a dog in this fight.
You know what I mean?
Like I want to win.
I don't want to see these places that I love destroyed.
Right.
Whether those are the places that I live,
like in Pennsylvania or the places that I've visited that are remarkable and
that are on the chopping block,
you know,
and especially because there are places that have been destroyed.
It's not like these are theoretical ideas that may or may not come to fruition.
No,
absolutely.
You can go to North Dakota and you can look at that fucking spot and see those
poor people.
That sand thing is freaking me the fuck out.
I need to see that.
And He'd be cds.
There's,
there's a Facebook,
a sand called oil feel fails.
I think it's Facebook page.
It's really,
it's actually more popular than gas and page.
They have like 140,000 followers.
We have 115,000 followers.
It's like oil field fails on Facebook has like crazy stuff on it.
It's like burning explosions,
directional drilling gone awry where they're shooting fracking fluids out into a
field,
Halliburton trucks and they make memes out of them.
It's like a Halliburton truck looked like overturned.
It says go home Halliburton,
you're drunk like stuff and it's for comic value among dudes in the oil and gas
industry and you can just go on there and it's all these blatant really
dangerous situations.
Human rights abuses,
people like bathing and chemicals out in the open on Facebook.
If you found it.
Oilfield fails on Facebook are good.
One is there.
They did some whole bunch of holiday stuff that's not that fine.
Oh well there's a lot of like,
you know like,
or look up directional drilling,
fail and Youtube or whatever.
Um,
yeah,
like you've got it there.
You've got the,
the,
the podcast.
I mean the,
the Facebook page.
Yeah.
See there's a broken,
there's a truck with fallen off the road and another truck was fallen off the
road and these are just guys that are fucked up.
Yeah.
And that's where I saw the backend beach or whatever like um,
uh,
with the dude's like hanging out at the,
at the,
she's a huge crane that's phone or I mean some of it is funny,
it's like bloopers.
But then when you realize that these are people who could be dead because of
that truck accident or um,
you know,
imperiled by,
there's a flare you to see one of the flares and the window of the store where I
don't understand what's going on in that picture.
Yeah.
Um,
okay,
so you saw the,
you see that's a reflection in the window of a flare across the street.
Oh really?
How do you know what's in a store?
It's not in the store.
It looks like it.
It looks like it's confusing.
Okay.
So you see that those types of flares are what is our,
what makes that,
and those things are just burning off this natural gas that they're trying to
get rid of because it's not what they're looking for.
Right.
And by doing that,
you're polluting,
I'm sure you fucking burning,
you're burning CO2,
you're burning unrefined gas,
which also has a lot of other stuff in it besides just method.
What is that?
Documentaries,
the overnighters.
Is that what it is?
Yeah,
that's about it.
I haven't seen it yet.
It's about North Dakota.
About the,
the crazy,
it's really good.
Yeah,
I've heard it's really good as well.
The,
the,
the just the nutty gas industry and all these crazy colorful characters.
I used the word colorful very lightly.
I haven't seen it.
I have not seen supposed to be great,
but listen,
um,
I think what you're doing is awesome.
Thank you know,
it's uh,
uh,
you know,
I'll fucking,
people that agree and disagree.
It's like a very hotly debated subject on my message board and on Twitter page.
And some people are so fucking angry.
You,
it's,
it's interesting.
I don't think they're real people.
I think some of those people might be real.
People have a lot,
a lot of them are real.
A lot of them are trolls,
but not a lot of them aren't man.
These people that I know,
these are people that have been on my message board for years.
Something to talk about,
all sorts of things,
but they lock on to those conservative ideals was conservative talking pot.
All I would say is like this is not a progressive or conservative issue.
This is about science.
Yeah,
and I would invite those folks who are getting angry at me to go to physicians,
scientists and engineers website.
Just type it in.
Physicians,
scientists and engineers for healthy energy at their website are 400 peer
reviewed scientific papers,
cross listed by topic on everything that we report on and they back up what we
report on sub substantively in every case.
Well.
So if you're one of those people who decides that cell phones work by magic or
your car works because you sprinkle Pixie dust under the hood,
then fine.
But if you're going to participate in the modern world,
which you need to do is he'd what science is saying to you and science is saying
very decisively at this point,
fracking does all the things described in the gas nine films.
It creates flammable water and creates water contamination.
It creates chemicals in water,
creates air pollution.
It creates health effects.
It creates civil unrest.
It creates fractured communities.
All of these things can be studied from objective scientific standpoint and had
come out to be proven and true from the standpoint of science and reporting so
that people are getting mad at me about it.
Look inward.
No way you're getting mad about,
you've got to come to the F to grips with the fact that if you're participating
in this way and you don't believe that this is an object of witchcraft,
then you must deal with the fact that you're wrong.
The Twitter page is gas land movie.
Um,
your website or the Twitter is gasoline movie and the website has gasoline land,
the movie.com.
I also mentioned our new project,
which is solutions grassroots.com,
which is the renewable energy,
uh,
and democracy organizing pub that we're trying for.
Thank you very much,
man.
Thank you.
It's on really fun.
Josh Fox.
Ladies and gentlemen,
we'll be back tomorrow with the Great Russell Peters and a until then,
we'll see you soon.
Thank you.
Much love.